That feeling of just knowing
a game is right for you
when you first lay eyes on it
is such a great feeling.
The thing that happens is
you start to feel the excitement
just build up.
I'm thinking about it all the
time, even in my sleep.
-I play video games
because I love stories.
-Experiencing worlds that you
can't experience as yourself.
-I guess video games allow me
to be what I can't.
It's fiction, but it's not.
-You come home,
log on to your PC,
and disappear
into a different world.
-I am a part of
something bigger,
a part of something beautiful.
-As an autistic person,
video games gave me a place
where I could be in a world
that made sense to me.
-I will tell you that all of my
family play video games.
-Me and my brothers,
we would share
the computer one hour at a time.
I'm really enjoying
playing video games with my dad.
-...my children.
-...my little sister.
That connection
between video games
allowing us
to converse with each other
added a lot to our relationship.
-Games like World of Warcraft
let me meet people
that I probably
never would have.
-I can honestly say
that I've met
some of my best friends
through playing games.
-We have this connection that
allows us to share our joys,
to share our achievements,
to share our growth together.
-Every time I'm able
to achieve something,
I'm able to make myself proud.
-Killing Heroic Blackhand
back in Warlords of Draenor
was one of my favorite memories.
-I managed to find
that one hidden Pylon
with my one Mutalisk.
-We beat Hardcore
Inferno Diablo.
-I was able to hit Gold in
Competitive in Overwatch.
-I had someone say,
"Oh, I can't lose to a girl."
And I beat that guy.
I was able to slay this warlock
as a little gnome holy priest,
freaking out
and screaming the whole time.
-The adrenaline through my body
was going crazy!
-"I killed the Lich King!
I killed the Lich King!"
-Many years ago, I was doing a
quest in Terokkar Forest,
and a lovely little mage
came up and said,
"Would you like a hand?"
They helped me
for the rest of the day.
We've been married now
for over a decade.
-Those video games
filled a void.
They filled the friendships
I didn't have.
There isn't a huge
LGBTQIA+ community in my city,
so when I was able
to play a video game,
I was able to start talking
with people
who didn't really care
that I was a gay male.
-Video games were my escape.
When I was a teenager
my dad was diagnosed with ALS,
and I looked to video games
as a way
to escape
from that sort of reality.
Everything happens for a reason,
and I'm glad video games
were there for me.
I'll never stop playing
video games.
-There's no way.
-I imagine myself, one day,
being an 80-year-old
grandpa gamer.
-Playing video games
has shaped me.
I don't think I would be
who I am today.
-My passion, my interest,
my excitement, they belong.
-Video games opened,
for me, the world...
-...and because of that,
I'm forever thankful.
-And I can't wait to see
what the next generation holds.
# EPIC ORCHESTRAL MUSIC
# MUSIC CRESCENDOS
Welcome to BlizzConline,
a celebration of 30 years
of Blizzard communities
and 30 years of Blizzard games.
Thirty years is so many years,
and last year maybe felt
like one of the longest of all.
But throughout the years
of Blizzard Entertainment,
from 1991 to today,
many of us can associate
certain games
with milestones in our lives.
Maybe you were a little kid
the first time you played
The Lost Vikings,
or in high school when you first
played a Diablo game,
or maybe you met your partner
while you were playing
World of Warcraft.
That's the awesome thing
about video games.
They give us experiences
that are relevant
to the times in our lives,
and experiences
that we carry forward with us.
Games are here
for us during good times,
and they're here for us
even when we feel alone,
or maybe uncertain.
Games are coming home:
familiar,
comfortable,
with a connection
and a sense of belonging.
And while many of us
spent most of 2020
in our actual real-life homes,
games became even more
of a place to get away,
to be free
from outside concerns...
even if just for a little while.
So... this is pretty weird.
Usually when we start BlizzCon,
the opening call is
to my favorite Warcraft faction,
the Alliance.
# ORCHESTRAL MUSIC
Or is my favorite faction
the Horde?
I get confused.
Usually I'd be speaking
to 40,000 of you in person
at the Anaheim
Convention Center,
and millions of you
around the world.
And usually that would be a
perfect way to celebrate.
But nothing about the last year
has been usual.
The pandemic has been
hard on everyone,
and for many different reasons.
But if there's one thing that
the last year has taught us,
it's that being apart physically
doesn't stop us
from moving forward.
It doesn't stop us
from connecting
with our player friends
around the world,
diving in as warriors
and heroes...
and checking on each other
as humans.
It doesn't stop us from sharing
our latest epic gaming story,
or celebrating those of others.
Games continue to unite us.
Now, to be honest,
I wasn't sure how well
Blizzard could work from home.
There are thousands of people,
all needing to work together
in creating our universes,
games and experiences.
Never has it felt more true
that it takes a Blizzard
to make a Blizzard game.
And in 2020, it became clear
that the magic of creating
at Blizzard
isn't just tied
to a physical location.
It's tied to the people
who work here,
and I continue to be so proud of
each and every one of them.
Thank you, Blizzard.
We create these games
and pour all of our energy
and heart into them,
but it is you,
the Blizzard community,
that brings them to life.
And that's why BlizzConline
is a celebration of you:
the guild leaders,
healers,
DPS,
tanks,
innkeepers,
Zerg,
Terran,
Protoss,
Blackwatch,
Shimada,
the heroes of Sanctuary,
and of the Storm.
These next few days are for you,
our Blizzard community.
For World of Warcraft,
we'll be showing you what's next
for both Shadowlands
and Classic.
I'm sure you're all burning
in anticipation for that one.
Hearthstone is getting back to
its roots in a major way.
We can't wait to show you how.
We also have news
for our Diablo community.
Some of you were able to
dip your toes
into the depths of hell
in the Diablo Immortal
Technical Alpha.
Personally, I really enjoyed
seeing players embrace
the multiplayer aspect
of meeting in town.
We can't wait for more of you
to get your hands on it.
So, it's only the beginning
of the year,
and already there is so much to
look forward to,
even though we can't yet
be together in person.
The Overwatch League will be
kicking things off in spring,
and we'll be watching closely to
see if the San Francisco Shock
can continue
their championship run.
World of Warcraft
esports is back,
with the Arena World
Championship
and Mythic Dungeon International
already in full swing
in Shadowlands.
StarCraft II and Warcraft III
esports are going strong
with our friends
at the ESL Pro Tour.
And qualifiers
are already underway
for the first online stop of the
2021 Hearthstone Masters Tour,
with the first event taking
place next month.
But before
we get too far ahead...
let's take a look one last time
to when times
were a little simpler.
In the early 1990s,
the Internet was a baby.
CD sales had finally eclipsed
cassette tapes.
A cassette tape, it's a
rectangular piece of plastic,
and there's tape inside that
music would get recorded on,
and sometimes
you needed a pencil
to wind it and make it tight.
I know, it sounds crazy.
We were all playing video games
on Super Nintendo,
Sega Genesis, DOS, or Mac/PCs.
I personally was a master of
CONFIG.SYS and AUTOEXEC.BAT.
So many simple things,
in simple times.
If only we could relive them.
WIND WHOOSHING
# SUSPENSEFUL MUSIC
# '90s ARCADE MUSIC
VOICEOVER: The stage is set.
The green flag drops!
Let the carnage begin!
Holy Toledo!
What a collection!
Now we're talking!
What a play!
Crank up the volume!
# '90s ARCADE
ROCK 'N' ROLL MUSIC
Unbelievable!
Whoa!
The Blizzard Arcade Collection,
featuring The Lost Vikings, Rock
n' Roll Racing, and Blackthorne.
These are ports of the games
just as you remember them,
allowing you to relive
the original experience
of all three titles
in 13 different languages,
with a couple of
quality-of-life upgrades.
As an example,
we include very modern,
cutting-edge functionality
that wasn't available
in the early '90s:
both saving
and loading of games.
And for those of you
who purchased
any Blizzard digital
anniversary bundle
via Battle.net,
you'll automatically receive
the Blizzard Arcade Collection
on PC today.
Now, you ready to hear about
some other video games?
Let's hear what's next
for World of Warcraft.
# DRAMATIC ORCHESTRAL MUSIC
SNARLS
Hello, everyone!
Thanks for joining us today.
No matter where you are,
World of Warcraft unites us all.
Whether you're exploring
the Shadowlands,
Classic Azeroth, or another part
of the Blizzard universe,
I'm glad you could make it,
because we've got
a lot of good stuff to show you.
But first,
let's start
with some Covenant pride.
Kyrian, take flight!
Night Fae, let the hunt begin!
Necrolords,
to war!
Venthyr, let's party.
The world has thrown a lot at us
since the last BlizzCon,
and the thing that's really kept
everyone going on the WoW team
has been connecting
with all of you.
The bonds we forge
with our guilds
and family and friends in WoW
are powerful and real.
As WoW enters its 16th year
and Blizzard celebrates
its 30th anniversary,
we're so grateful
to have the most dedicated
and friendly communities
in gaming.
Let's recap
the events in Azeroth.
In WoW Classic,
we fought an endless battle
for Southshore and Tarren Mill.
We banded together
to open the gates of Ahn'Qiraj,
and joined forces
to take down Kel'Thuzad
in his floating citadel
of Naxxramas.
In Shadowlands,
we helped our Covenant
recover from the anima drought
brought on by Sire Denathrius,
master of the Venthyr
and traitor
to the Pantheon of Death.
We survived
the halls of Torghast
and crafted Legendary gear
in our efforts
to expel Denathrius
from his castle lair.
But innocent souls
are still wrongfully being sent
to the Maw.
They face
an eternity of torment,
and heroes like Anduin
remain chained in its depths.
The Jailer
continues to grow in power.
He's preparing
to break free from the Maw
and complete his plan to unmake
the entire Warcraft universe.
And Sylvanas,
you may be wondering what
she's been up to all this time.
Today, we're excited to unveil
our first major content update
for Shadowlands:
Chains of Domination.
# DRAMATIC ORCHESTRAL MUSIC
ANDUIN: Look around you!
What makes you believe
you're not just a weapon
to achieve his ends?
Enough!
Join our cause
or be made to serve.
Right now,
you hold all the power.
Make your choice,
Sylvanas Windrunner.
WIND WHOOSHING
THENIOS:
Despite all our efforts,
the Maw continues to grow.
What if Denathrius's treachery
is irreparable?
The Primus is lost,
and Bastion cannot save
the Shadowlands alone.
None of this
should have happened.
Perhaps
the Winter Queen could...
WINGS FLAPPING
My Archon...
a living soul seeks an audience.
A mortal?
A king.
# UPLIFTING ORCHESTRAL MUSIC
KLEIA: By all our measures...
one who has spent his life
striving for justice.
One who would give anything
to serve his people.
One whose heart...
is true.
Very well.
He may approach.
Step forward.
My Ascended have spoken of you.
The king
held captive in the Maw.
That prison
could not hold me forever.
Why have you come to Bastion?
You have a key... that I need.
You...
will release
this soul from your grasp!
ANDUIN: No.
He is bound to me...
JAILER: ...just as you once
sought to bind your own brother!
# DRAMATIC ORCHESTRAL MUSIC
ANDUIN GRUNTS, ARCHON SCREAMS
PANTING
GASPS
# OMINOUS ORCHESTRAL MUSIC
JAILER: The vessel performed
its part flawlessly.
Three keys remain.
Then they will see...
Death was never meant
to be chained.
That is so intense.
I know you probably
have a lot of questions
about what you just saw,
and what it means
for the next stage
of your Shadowlands journey.
Later today,
my teammates Ion and Jeremy
will be telling you more about
Chains of Domination
in our Shadowlands update.
Please check out
the World of Warcraft channel
to find out more.
Next, I'm excited
to share our upcoming
World of Warcraft
Charity Pet Program.
We've heard a lot
from our community
about how much
they love these pets
and the opportunity
to give to a good cause,
along with ideas
to make the program even better.
So during this
upcoming campaign,
you'll be able to donate
whatever amount you wish
to directly support
our chosen charity.
Once donations reach our goal,
everyone playing
World of Warcraft
will get a pet
for their collection
as a thank you,
whether you were able to
contribute personally or not.
And to make this
a fun challenge,
if we reach a stretch goal,
everyone gets a second pet, too.
And here they are.
The first pet is Bananas!
Literally.
He was originally available
to a select few
back in the Burning Crusade era,
so we're excited to give
everyone a chance to adopt him.
And if we reach
our stretch goal,
you'll also get Daisy the Sloth.
DAISY GRUNTS
She's an all-new pet
who will hang around your neck
when you need a hug.
Your donations during this
campaign will go to support
the medical humanitarian
organization
Doctors Without Borders,
also known by their French name
Médecins Sans Frontières,
or MSF.
They're an amazing group doing
important work around the world.
We're grateful to have
such a generous community,
and we hope you'll help support
this worthy cause.
We'll be sharing the details
about the Charity Pet Program
on the World of Warcraft
website soon.
So, we've talked quite a bit
about Shadowlands.
Classic players,
now it's your turn.
It's my pleasure to hand off
to my teammate Holly Longdale.
She's a long-time WoW player,
a veteran MMO developer,
and she's going to tell us
what's in store for WoW Classic.
# DRAMATIC
ORCHESTRAL MUSIC
BIRDS CAWING
ROARS
Hi, everybody.
First,
I'd like to thank all of you
who have ever been part
of the WoW community
over the years.
You know, online worlds like WoW
have been a huge part of our
lives for decades now.
As a dedicated MMO fan
and a developer myself,
I remember hearing
that Blizzard was going to be
making their own MMO,
and I thought, "Well, I guess
I'll check out that beta."
And, sure,
we all call the game WoW,
but really, wow!
(CHUCKLES) I could not believe I
got bit by the MMO bug again.
I was so excited to be able to
make a Night Elf Hunter
and be like that famous
Dark Elf Ranger
from the books that I loved.
I have to tell you,
Azeroth was, and still is,
a place I love to live.
Since last year,
I've had the great honor to work
alongside the WoW Classic team
to bring
these nostalgic experiences
back to life for long-time fans
and a whole new generation
of players.
As a fan myself,
I've had so much fun in WoW.
From the simple things,
like drive-by buffing,
or making friends
on that long haul
from Teldrassil to Ironforge,
all the way
to the absolutely staggering,
like when I jumped blindly
through the Dark Portal
and was running through
Hellfire Peninsula,
heard this terrifying noise,
and then saw the Fel Reaver.
Biggest roamer I had ever seen,
and I was very glad I had Feign
Death in that moment.
And that's the thing about WoW:
These stories
and experiences we all share
keep us coming back
time after time.
With that said,
I'm super excited
to be able to share with you
where our adventures
are taking us next.
WIND HOWLING
THUNDER RUMBLING
THUNDER CRASHES
ETHEREAL HOWLING
ILLIDAN STORMRAGE:
You dare enter my realm?
# DRAMATIC ORCHESTRAL
MUSIC BUILDS
MAGTHERIDON ROARS
ORC ROARS
GRUUL ROARS
ELEKK BELLOWS
LAUGHTER
GRUUL: Gruul smash!
PRINCE MALCHEZAAR:
Your foolishness
has brought you to this end.
MAGTHERIDON:
Take my blood and choke on it!
LADY VASHJ:
Death to the outsiders!
KAEL'THAS SUNSTRIDER: I'll turn
your world upside down!
ILLIDAN STORMRAGE:
You are not prepared!
Brings back
so many memories, right?
Like exploring the fungal
forests of Zangarmarsh,
or being awestruck
at the chaotic magic
alive in Netherstorm.
The Draenei in Exodar,
the Blood Elves in Silvermoon -
I loved playing them both.
Do you choose to enlist
the Aldor or the Scryers
in your quest
to fight the Legion?
And, of course, we can't forget,
gathering all your friends
to fight Illidan
at the top of the Black Temple.
I can't wait
to relive it all with you.
Since the team first set out
on their own quest
to bring the original
WoW back to life,
we have learned a ton
about what players are expecting
from this kind of experience.
We've also learned when to keep
things just as they were,
and where we all might be open
to some changes.
We're bringing all these lessons
into Burning Crusade Classic,
with our primary goal to bring
back the same feeling you had
when you faced the Fel Reaver
for the first time,
or when you were digging through
piles of Fellhound poop.
Of course, we can't
get this right without you,
our incredible community.
Soon, you'll be able
to revisit Outland yourself
when beta starts,
and tell us what you think.
Later, all WoW Classic players
are going to be presented
with a meaningful choice
for each one
of your beloved characters.
Do you want to move on
into Burning Crusade Classic,
or do you want to stay in the
original Classic era forever?
Whatever you decide,
you can do it all
with your one WoW subscription.
Now, I know I've thrown
a lot at you, but don't worry.
We'll be getting
into the details
in our panel later today,
so stick with us.
We'll make sure
you are prepared.
And now we're going to hear
what's coming up in Hearthstone.
# FAIRGROUND MUSIC
# HEARTHSTONE THEME MUSIC
Greetings.
We're truly excited
to share with you
everything that's coming
to Hearthstone this year.
But first,
let's take a quick look back
at the Year of the Phoenix.
We added our first new class,
the Demon Hunter,
and ventured
into the ruthless Outlands.
Then we went
to Scholomance Academy
and got to explore
Dual-Class cards
and their powerful synergies.
And with our third expansion
of the year,
we brought you Hearthstone's
biggest update ever,
alongside the menacing Old Gods
in Madness
at the Darkmoon Faire.
We launched a brand-new
game mode, Duels,
that saw more than ten million
matches on its first day.
We also introduced our
long-awaited achievement system
and made a significant overhaul
to the rewards and progression
within the game.
Now it's time to say farewell
to the Year of the Phoenix
and see what's in store
for Hearthstone this year.
Welcome
to the Year of the Griffin.
Over the last couple of years
we've made
big changes to Hearthstone.
Throughout
the Year of the Griffin,
we want to keep delivering
fun new experiences,
and make sure
that the tens of millions
of you playing Hearthstone
are always excited to log in.
First up,
we'll be giving the standard
format its biggest shake-up ever
with the launch of the Core Set
later this year.
The Core Set replaces
the old Basic and Classic sets
with a collection of 235 cards
made up of some of the best
from throughout the years,
as well as 29 awesome
brand-new cards.
And the best thing
about the Core Set
is that it's entirely free,
so there's never been a better
time to get into Hearthstone.
Here are three of Hearthstone's
Legendary Dragons,
reimagined to feel more
up-to-date and competitive
for modern-day Hearthstone.
Ysera the Dreamer.
You'll finally receive
her full arsenal
of Dream cards right away.
She's a nightmare
for your opponents.
Malygos the Spellweaver.
He'll fill your hand with spells
and is a powerful
late-game play.
Worthy of the Aspect of Magic.
And finally,
everyone's favorite
black dragon...
Deathwing.
He's still
as destructive as ever,
but timed correctly,
he won't leave you empty-handed.
We'll also be launching
a brand-new format:
Classic,
where you can play Hearthstone
as it was
when it first launched.
The Classic format
will be fully supported,
complete with ranks and rewards
using Hearthstone's
original set of cards.
So,
if you want to relive
the old-school experience,
then Classic
is the place for you.
With Classic
revisiting the past,
now let's take a look
to the future
and explore the first expansion
of the Year of the Griffin.
# OMINOUS MUSIC
SAURFANG:
For a hero of the Horde...
all roads lead
to the Crossroads.
You have come for "adventure."
But the Barrens
wants to break you.
Your axe...
WOLF SNARLS
...must be sharp.
Your wits...
must be keen.
And your heart...
must be mighty.
SNARLING
SCREECHING
HORN BELLOWS
ORCS CHANTING
SAURFANG: Strength...
and honor.
This is who we are.
ORCS CHANTING
ROKARA: For the Horde!
That's right,
we're headed to one of
Warcraft's most iconic locales,
the Barrens,
and we'll come face-to-face
with the heroes that inhabit it,
starting with one of the Horde's
most iconic
and well-known characters -
a fierce loyalist,
one-time war chief,
that embodies the honor, loyalty
and spirituality of the Horde:
Shadow Hunter Vol'jin.
Shadow Hunter Vol'jin
is a neutral Legendary
that allows you
to either bolster your own board
or weaken that
of your opponent's.
And to celebrate
the announcement
of Forged in the Barrens,
this card is available for free,
for everyone, later today.
So log in to Hearthstone
and claim your free copy
of Shadow Hunter Vol'jin.
And as a bonus...
we're also giving away
the brand-new
30 Years of Blizzard card back.
Next, we have another hero
of the Horde,
who is making his first
appearance in Hearthstone.
The legendary
Blademaster Samuro,
featuring
the new keyword Frenzy.
Frenzy activates the first time
a minion takes damage
and survives.
In Samuro's case,
this can be used
to clear your opponent's board.
Heroes of the Horde,
like Samuro,
are famous
for their combat prowess,
but others, like Thrall,
are known for their powerful
elemental magic.
Take a look at this new Shaman
spell, Chain Lightning.
Chain Lightning is a spell
in a new cycle of cards
that rank up
and become more powerful
when you have 5 and 10 mana,
ensuring
that they're always useful
at every stage in the game.
You'll also notice that they're
categorized as Nature spells.
With Forged in the Barrens,
we'll be permanently introducing
spell schools
across the entire game,
which enables a whole host
of exciting new strategies.
And don't worry,
members of the Alliance.
We'll be featuring
some of your most beloved heroes
and locales later this year.
But what I love most
about the Warcraft universe
is its amazing characters,
and our final announcement
is our most ambitious addition
to Hearthstone yet.
It introduces a brand-new way
to play
with your favorite heroes.
Hearthstone Mercenaries.
Mercenaries features
strategic RPG gameplay,
where you build teams
consisting of some of the most
iconic heroes and villains
from the Warcraft universe.
Including timeless characters
like the infamous
Sylvanas Windrunner...
and Ragnaros,
the Elemental Lord of Fire.
You can also expect to see some
of Hearthstone's fan favorites,
like the unstoppable Devilsaur,
King Krush,
and the ever-growing
Gruul the Dragonslayer.
You'll lead them in battle
through highly replayable
roguelike missions,
where the map is randomly
generated every time you play,
and each node represents
a unique challenge
for your team to take on.
Your heroes gain levels,
new abilities, equipment,
and can even evolve into more
powerful versions of themselves.
We're thrilled to finally show
you Hearthstone Mercenaries.
It is scheduled to launch
later this year,
and we'll have more to share
with you down the road.
Everything you've seen today
is just a taste of what's coming
in the Year of the Griffin,
so don't forget to tune in
to our deep-dive panel
after the Opening Ceremony,
where we'll share more details
on the Core Set,
the new Classic format,
Forged in the Barrens,
and our plans
for Battlegrounds and Duels,
as well as our upcoming
single-player content.
I want to thank the team
for their amazing work.
And on behalf of all of us
at Hearthstone,
we want to thank
the many millions of you
who play our game.
Your dedication and support
is what drives us
to make awesome updates
and pursue ambitious
and fun ideas.
We can't wait to kick off
the Year of the Griffin
with all of you,
and we hope to see you
in the game soon.
Next up, you'll get an update
on all things Diablo.
ROARS
# DRAMATIC ORCHESTRAL MUSIC
Hey, everyone.
Thank you very much
for joining us.
I am so excited to kick off
the Diablo segment of our show,
and I am honored to be here
on behalf of all
of our Diablo teams
to share the news and updates
we have in store for you today.
We've got a lot
of Diablo to cover,
and I hope you'll agree with me
that it's a great time to be a
member of this community.
Alright, let's kick things off
with Diablo IV.
We first shared our game with
you during BlizzCon of 2019,
and we've been truly humbled
by your response.
We've kept in touch
through quarterly updates,
and sincerely appreciate
the thoughts
and valuable feedback
you've provided
as we unveil more
and more of the game
and share in its development.
After all, Diablo belongs to you
as much as it belongs to us.
Most recently, we teased an
update to our campfire screen,
and savvy fans,
of course, understood
that we meant more than just
the character lighting
and fire visual effects.
That's right,
today we're happy to announce
a brave new soul
joining the Barbarian,
the Sorcerer and the Druid
on this dangerous journey
back to Sanctuary.
A class is one
of the most exciting things
that you can announce
in a Diablo game.
This one is especially
exciting to me,
as it's a re-envisioning
of one of the first classes
to ever appear in the series.
Let's have a look.
# SOMBER ORCHESTRAL MUSIC
PRIEST: Your prayers do not fall
on deaf ears.
Just know they are being heard.
There is justice
within the Light...
but you have to be patient.
Now, pray with me.
May Akarat guide and protect me.
PARISHIONER:
May he shepherd my soul...
...and grant it mercy.
APPROACHING FOOTSTEPS
What are you doing here?
This is not the time.
But this is confession.
And I have sinned.
I was a thief...
who stole
from those more fortunate.
COINS JINGLE
I strayed from your Light...
and found my trade
in the Shadows.
They call it murder.
I say job well done.
GRUNTS
GROANS
PRIEST: Stop.
Stop!
Enough!
ROGUE: I am a thief...
a heretic...
a murderer, Father.
Will Akarat save me?
PRIEST GRUNTS
You mock our Light...
but those monsters
were a scourge upon my flock.
And you... (SCOFFS)
...you were the answer
to their prayers.
ROGUE: Then we are settled.
And you owe me.
The name you seek is...
(INDISTINCT WHISPERING)
Thank the Heavens for you.
Heavens?
I assure you, Father...
the Heavens didn't send me.
# DRAMATIC ORCHESTRAL MUSIC
FIGHTING GRUNTS
# SOMBER ORCHESTRAL MUSIC
DOORS SLAM
Just the sound of that ear
getting pierced
by the hook is so brutal.
I feel like it's going to
haunt me for a long time.
I've been a huge fan
of the Rogue
ever since the original Diablo.
Even seeing them come back
as NPCs and Mercenaries
in Diablo II's Rogue Encampment
served as a great bridge
between the games.
With the setting of Diablo IV
being a larger world
than we've ever
played in before,
we're excited to show you
not just what the successors
to the original Rogues
in the series
have been up to
since the fall of their order,
but also what some
of the other Rogues
in the world of Sanctuary
might look like.
The mantra for Diablo IV has
been "customization first,"
and the Rogue takes this
to a whole new level.
From the beginning,
the Rogue has been
an incredibly flexible class,
able to adapt to any situation.
Our goal is to let you create
the kind of Rogue
that you want to play,
whether it's
an unrivalled archer
modelled after
the original Sisterhood,
or a cloak-and-dagger Rogue
from the darkest
alleys of Caldeum.
In Diablo IV,
you will have the freedom
to create
the Rogue that you imagine,
by customizing the looks,
the background
and the playstyle
of your character.
Please stick around
for our segment later today,
where I'll be joined by other
members of the Diablo IV team
to share a closer look
at the Rogue class,
as well as some
of the open-world gameplay
that we're bringing to the game.
Spoilers:
those severed ears
are not just for show.
But Diablo IV
is not the only Diablo game
we're talking about today.
If you're looking
for an authentic
Diablo experience on mobile,
we've got you covered.
Diablo Immortal has everything
you'd expect
from an AAA action-RPG,
from the visceral combat
and epic loot,
to an all-new story
bridging the gap
between the events
of Diablo II and Diablo III.
Later today
you can join the Immortal team,
where they'll talk about some of
the things they've learned
from the recent alpha test,
and what's next for the game.
But that's still not all.
We have one last bit of very
exciting Diablo news to cover.
When you hear us talk
about the classes,
the items or the stories
of the early Diablo games,
you may have picked up
on the absolute reverent
tone we reserve
for that golden era of Diablo.
Maybe you share
that love of the classics,
and just hearing us
talk about them
makes you want
to take on Mephisto
or Baal one more time, or maybe
even for the first time.
After all,
some of our favorite moments
happened a long time ago,
and not just in Sanctuary years.
If so, we have a special
surprise for you today.
Let's check it out.
ETHEREAL WHISPERING
BAAL: How was it not your fault?
MARIUS: The Wanderer...
THE WANDERER: Now you know
what I seek, Marius.
BAAL: Enough!
MARIUS: Were these the demons
from my dream?
TYRAEL: Don't do it!
BAAL: It seems your terms...
TYRAEL: Fool!
BAAL: ...are not acceptable.
TAL RASHA:
Look what they've done to me.
MEPHISTO: Arise, Diablo,
Lord of Terror!
# SOMBER MUSIC
TYRAEL: Though this be
our darkest hour...
it may yet
be your greatest moment.
BARBARIAN ROARS
# OMINOUS ORCHESTRAL MUSIC
WEREWOLF SNARLS
DIABLO: Not even death
can save you from me.
After more than 20 years,
the Dark Wanderer has returned.
And once again,
he travels east -
always east.
Diablo II is a landmark game
for Blizzard.
Diablo II: Resurrected
is a full-HD remaster
of both the original game
and the expansion,
Lord of Destruction.
It takes the 2D, sprite-based
classic that we love
and brings it into
the present in 3D,
utilizing up-to-date
graphical rendering
and lighting technologies.
It also includes modernizing
all 27 minutes of cinematics,
recreated shot for shot,
with the explicit intention
of preserving both the look
and the pacing
of the original movies.
Blizzard has a long history
of games that we're proud of,
and when we think
about Diablo II,
we think about it
as a definitive pillar
in our foundation.
Now, it's funny to think
that some of you weren't even
born when DII was released,
which makes it
all the more important
that we deliver
an authentic experience,
wherever you play.
We want everyone
to relive their memories,
or experience the game
for the very first time,
on their platform of choice.
And so we're excited
to bring Diablo II: Resurrected
to PC and console,
along with cross-progression.
And for those of you who are in
love with the original
and you just wish
it worked more seamlessly
on modern computers,
you can bring back all
of that nostalgia
exactly as you remember,
and enjoy the game
in its original 2D form,
Later today, Diablo speedrunner
MrLlama will host a roundtable
with members
of the development team
on the dedicated Diablo channel.
If you are a Diablo II fan,
I encourage you to take a look.
So, from Diablo II: Resurrected
to Burning Crusade Classic,
to the Blizzard
Arcade Collection,
that's a whole
lot of looking back.
And while we have teams
dedicated
to bringing
these timeless experiences
into your hands,
it's actually a very small
percentage of our developers
working on these projects.
Far more people are working
on the future of Blizzard.
And in addition to what we'll be
talking about during the show,
we can't wait to tell you even
more about our plans
over the course
of this year and beyond.
If you had asked us 30 years ago
what gaming
would look like today,
none of us could have predicted
the current
Blizzard lineup of games.
The advances in technology
are one thing,
but it's really
what those advances have enabled
that's even more incredible.
If you think about
the people who play games
and the communities
that have grown up around them,
the way people
can connect instantly,
no matter where they are
in the world,
the way people are increasingly
able to express their identity
and celebrate who they are
through their favorite games,
communities
and platforms,
the explosion of things
like streaming,
cosplay and esports,
it would have been hard
to imagine
any of that 30 years ago.
And at Blizzard,
that is what excites us
about the next 30 years.
There is so much
that we're working on,
and some of it
you already know about.
The rest?
We look forward
to talking to you
about it when the time is right.
Just like the real world,
the worlds of Warcraft, Diablo,
StarCraft, Heroes of the Storm,
Overwatch and Hearthstone
are diverse,
expansive and full of potential.
We are not only iterating
on the experiences that you've
come to expect from us.
We're also exploring different
ways to express our worlds,
and welcome more players
from more places into them.
And we aspire
to continue to lead
on priorities like accessibility
and toxicity control,
and to continue
supporting causes
that have a positive impact
on the real world.
We want to continue to bring
those same feelings
of joy and achievement
that we all felt when we first
defeated the Lich King,
or beat Diablo on Hardcore mode,
because when we geek-out on
those experiences with others,
we can't help but see
the similarities between us
and feel what's possible
when we play together.
Of course,
there are new Blizzard worlds
that we haven't visited
quite yet.
And when we do finally unveil
those games and experiences,
our hope is that you will see in
them what we do -
that no matter who you are
or where you're from,
they are spaces where you can
create new stories,
forge new friendships,
and make memories
worthy of lasting a lifetime.
And through it all,
our mission statement
of being "dedicated to creating
the most epic entertainment
experiences... ever,"
along with our core values,
led by "gameplay first,"
will continue to guide our way.
So, on behalf of everyone
at Blizzard,
thank you for being
on this journey.
For me, personally,
it is the honor of my
professional life to serve you,
and the honor of all
of us at Blizzard
to be the caretakers
of the worlds that you play in.
We are so excited
for what's to come this year,
next year,
and the next 30 years.
Now,
what's coming next for the show?
Well,
it depends on where you watch.
For those of you looking
for an update on Overwatch,
check out the
behind-the-scenes look
into the development
of Overwatch 2
over on their dedicated channel,
right after the conclusion
of opening ceremonies.
There,
you'll hear about Overwatch 2,
new content, new features,
including new maps,
Hero Missions, Talent trees,
and more of what we think will
make Overwatch II
a unique gameplay experience.
For World of Warcraft,
Diablo and Hearthstone,
you'll get a closer look
on their respective channels.
And on the dedicated
strategy channel,
some StarCraft legends
will be going head-to-head
in epic competition.
Once again,
welcome to BlizzConline.
Be good to one another.
Welcome home.
Before we kick things off,
here's a little something from a
previous BlizzCon headliner.
ENGINE REVVING LOUDLY
# HIP-HOP MUSIC
HORN BEEPS
BIG VIKING: Ha-ha-ha! Woo!
SMALL VIKING: I'm king
of the world!
-SMALL VIKING: Whoa!
-LARGE VIKING: Hey!
Ha-ha!
ENGINE REVVING MORE LOUDLY
VIKINGS SCREAM
GROANING
For the Horde!
For Lordaeron!
Argh!
METAL CLANGING
GRUNTING AND GROANING
# GUITAR CHORDS
What can I do for you?
What can I do...
Your death will...
GRUNTING AND GROANING
GRUNTING
Huh-rawr!
CREATURES YELLING
Argh!
Mortar, Vespa, Gaia...
Help!
Hoo!
SCREAMING
(LAUGHING) Get the Warlocks!
Get the Warchiefs.
Strike with great accuracy!
# EPIC WAR MUSIC
GRUNTING
You are not prepared!
Frostmourne hungers
for your soul!
SCREAMING
Your time has come.
Go, go, go!
GRUNTING
Woo-hoo!
Argh!
-Ugh!
-Ya!
Oh!
(TREMBLING) Whoa! Oh!
Oh! Oh.
CHUCKLES NERVOUSLY
No.
Hmm.
Mmm, oh...
No-uh!
Strange.
Death...
Rawr!
LAUGHING
Greetings to you.
Seems you're ready
for the real thing.
Huh!
Watch your back.
GRUNTING
The cavalry's here.
F it up!
Hey! Look at me.
Oh, it looks like
we got an audience.
I'm getting good at this.
# ELECTRONIC DANCE MUSIC
I'm in the groove.
Turret online.
LAUGHTER
Surprise!
Piece of cake.
MUSIC STOPS
# EPIC MUSIC
DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS
Welcome, everyone, to our Deep
Dive panel for WoW Classic.
I'd like to start
with some introductions,
with these fine gentlemen
with me, and myself.
I'm Holly Longdale.
I'm the principal producer
for WoW Classic.
A little bit about
my background,
I spent 13 years
working on EverQuest,
I started as a game designer,
and eventually became
the head of the studio
for the EverQuest franchise.
That said, I've always been
a WoW player, since beta,
so this is obviously a dream
come true for me,
and I'm thrilled
to be here with you.
I'm Patrick Dawson.
I'm the production director
for World of Warcraft.
I've been at Blizzard
for 15 years now,
and have been on WoW
for most of that time.
I'm an avid WoW player myself,
and really excited to open up
that Dark Portal again
as we all step through it.
And my name's Brian Birmingham,
and I'm the lead software
engineer on WoW Classic.
I've also been at Blizzard
for 15 years.
I started on World of Warcraft.
I spent about three years on
Hearthstone as well,
then came back to
the World of Warcraft team
to work on WoW Classic,
and it has been a great joy
to me to work on this team.
-There's a lot to talk about.
-Yeah.
So, earlier we announced Burning
Crusade Classic is coming.
But there's a lot more to it.
Let's take a look
at the features, 'cause...
Wow.
I mean, wow, right?
-Wow.
-(BRIAN LAUGHS)
I was so excited by
playing draenei and blood elves.
HOLLY: I played both, and I will
say my heart's with Alliance.
PATRICK: Hm...
LAUGHTER
Quiet!
And I also took up jewelcrafting
on my draenei shaman.
I wanted to corner the market.
Just the whole notion of having
items with sockets, and just
exploring that whole system.
I'm also
a bit of a systems nerd.
So, I completely lost my time
for weeks in there.
LAUGHTER
Burning Crusade, I remember
being there back then.
It was our first expansion ever,
so all the new features was
this really cool moment of,
what's coming next?
What's gonna happen?
And one of the things that was
pretty impactful to the game was
Horde having paladins
and Alliance having shaman.
As an avid PvP-er myself,
I remember going back
and trying to fight shaman,
I was Alliance back then,
and just not understanding
that class at all
'cause my team didn't have it,
so I tried to poly them,
and they'd be Grounding Totem...
I didn't know what that was.
"Why are shaman immune to
everything? I don't unde--"
That's not what you said.
Yeah, but no, I did.
No, you said,
"They're cheating."
LAUGHTER
I understood
the polymorphed druids.
LAUGHTER
But shaman? Why?
Now I started to understand
shaman a little bit better,
we got some of their benefits,
I actually got to see totems
being placed
onto my side for once,
and got to see the frustration
of dealing with Bubble Hearth
on the other.
BRIAN LAUGHS
Yeah, I remember
when I was doing raids,
we were always jealous
of the Alliance
having paladins
for Blessing of Salvation.
People would be pulling aggro
off me, and I'd be yelling,
"Wait for three Sunders!"
LAUGHTER
And the Alliance just like,
"No, it's no problem,
just go. Just go."
-(LAUGHS)
-Yup.
So, you know, we were upset,
raiding Razergore
without Earthbind.
LAUGHTER
I mean, really, even the playing
field for both PvE and PvP
was kind of cool.
But there are a ton
of new features,
and instabilities with this too,
you know,
as we got to Level 70,
we got to experience new
concepts and new things.
I remember one of
my first experiences
with understanding
what it meant for...
Designed by Blizzard.
-BRIAN: Oh, yeah.
-I was an engineer, right?
I wasn't a designer,
I was working on the live ops
team at the time,
and, you know, I was playing
my class, avid player of mage,
and I kept, I sent this long
email to Tom Chilton,
saying, like,
"Hey. Here's what mage needs."
-LAUGHTER
-Dawson Manifesto.
-PATRICK: Yeah.
It was a well-thought-out
forum post.
LAUGHTER
And what was in it,
was things like,
"Bring back invisibility,
let's get a threat
to offer the class."
PATRICK: And I didn't tie
those two together.
Like, "That's pretty good.
Give me invisibility."
And just knowing that
that skill was coming,
along with some other
new stuff for mages,
like the Molten Armor
and the Ice Lances,
it was just really cool to see
all this new stuff
in Burning Crusade.
On the other side of that,
I was really excited
about Spell Reflect,
because I was frustrated
getting polymorphed,
and being able to reflect that
back on the mage...
As a mage, I was not excited
for you to get that.
LAUGHTER
-Alas.
-I guess you weren't.
LAUGHTER
And there were even
some PvE encounters
that had abilities
that you could reflect back.
I remember that was really fun,
to find ways to time that,
and use it
as a defensive ability as well.
-I was a hunter.
-BRIAN: Mm-hm.
Also a hunter.
BRIAN: So am I now.
I switched. (LAUGHS)
But I remember
just chasing beast master,
and just DPS, DPS, DPS...
-BRIAN: Yeah.
-PATRICK: Yep.
That was it.
That was the chase, yeah.
Talking about that too makes me
think of the arenas,
and the arena system.
PATRICK: That was
a whole new world for us.
With battlegrounds and
the way they worked before,
the way the matchmaking
happened,
usually I was
pretty competitive in PvP,
so I would either
get in there and
-stomp the enemy team...
-(HOLLY LAUGHS)
...who was there to be casual,
or, even though
we were a good team,
we weren't the best of the best,
so when we ended up going
against one of those teams,
it was just, like,
"Well, jeez, we're just getting
stomped now. This is tough."
Arenas gave everyone
an opportunity
to play against
equal-minded opponents, right?
PATRICK: So if you were
a little bit more casual,
you get the opportunity
to play against people
who weren't maybe
so competitive.
Or, if you were cutting-edge,
go for it.
Try to be the best of the best.
And what was great about that,
is that it really,
it spawned an esport.
-Yeah.
-That wasn't...
We didn't design it for that, we
just wanted people to have fun,
but when we noticed, like,
"Hey, everybody's playing this,
everybody's competing in this,
people are watching it,"
we had to embrace that.
PATRICK: We started
featuring it in BlizzCons,
and we have
been ever since.
BRIAN: Yeah, it's awesome.
I think one of my favorite
things to recollect
was the exciting zones
that you would travel through.
One of my favorite memories
was actually
in the first zone,
Hellfire Peninsula.
And it was adventuring around
in Hellfire Peninsula,
going around
and doing all those quests,
and always living in fear of
the fel reaver.
Because you'd be out there
collecting parts
from a broken zeppelin,
and you'd be fighting off
your helboars,
and all of a sudden you'd see
the screen start to shake,
and this thomp, thomp,
thomp, and then...
FEL REAVER ROARS
BRIAN: Bwaaah!
You're like, "Oh my God, I gotta
run, he's right on top of me."
That sound haunts my dreams.
Oh I know, yeah,
it's terrifying.
Even alive,
it's just, Feign Death.
-BRIAN: Yes!
-Feign Death.
-Yeah, just like that.
-LAUGHTER
And then the payoff when you
later go to Netherstorm,
and they give you
the quest, like,
"Could you get me a part
from inside the fel reaver?
You're gonna have to kill him."
And you're like, "That guy that
used to terrorize me?"
BRIAN: They're like,
"You could take him."
And that was such
an exciting payoff,
to be able to bring that
full circle
and go back and see him again.
For me, I snuck into beta.
I got really lucky,
because I could see
the construction sign
for some of the zones,
and of course I ignored it,
-and went and explored.
-(BRIAN LAUGHS)
So, I remember
running through Blade's Edge,
and just seeing
dragon carcasses and skeletons
impaled in the environment,
and then moving on
to Netherstorm,
I just was blown away,
even from Zangarmarsh,
all the way through.
HOLLY: Everything felt like
its own world.
And just to be able
to go through that,
and the delight of it,
and the epicness of it,
and then you come up to Area 52.
That's what I love about Wow,
is you can have epic,
epic storylines,
and still find lightness in it,
so I just loved it.
I love...
I'm an explorer, so...
For me, I remember Burning
Crusade really opened up
a new gameplay type for me.
I became a collector
in Burning Crusade, right?
And that started with
the Aldor and Scryer route.
'Cause I got my Aldor rep
all the way up,
and then I was thinking about
switching to Scryer,
and people were like,
"You're insane, don't do that."
LAUGHTER
And I was like, "I bet I can."
You know,
just a few people thought...
And I did.
And it was cool,
it was really fun,
but then I started
doing other things.
PATRICK: There are these new
mounts, and pets,
and I went back and
even got some of the older raps,
like Thorium Brotherhood
and Winterspring.
But then things like
Netherwing Ledge came out...
The world just opened up for me
in Burning Crusade,
to really start my collection.
Of course,
we also had flying mounts,
which I loved,
and then decided to play with
some friends on our PvP server,
and was running around Hellfire,
and, I...
Death from above,
which was likely just Pat.
-Probably.
-HOLLY: Yeah.
(LAUGHS) Were you flying around
harassing people, Pat?
I was getting
a lot of honorable kills.
-LAUGHTER
-Back in the day.
So, that's just a quick look at
some of our memories
for Burning Crusade.
-And that was 13 years ago.
-Mm-hm.
So that code has been
hanging around for 13 years.
And we're not just doing
a "save-as"
Burning Crusade Classic.
-No, it's harder than that.
-(HOLLY LAUGHS) Yeah.
So let's get into
some of those details.
So, one of the challenges
has been
that we don't actually want to
ship on the old code.
And the reason for that is
because it's got a lot of bugs,
and difficulties
with the architecture
that we don't wanna
have to deal with.
But we do want that old data.
And we talked about this
when we did the original launch
of Classic,
was how the data
is really the thing
that describes how the game is
supposed to be played
and what's supposed
to happen in it.
And so, we want
to bring that old data
and we want to run it
on the modern code.
The same as we did for Classic.
And there's 750,000 rows of
data, that we have to go through
and convert from their old
formats to their new formats,
and fortunately we have
really talented engineers,
and we run automated scripts
that go through this,
but even after
we've run these scripts,
we have to compare them
with how it used to behave,
and make sure that
we've converted correctly.
And then there's even
some things
that are making it more
difficult this time,
like the fact that we've made
a couple
of minor changes or bug fixes
in the Classic data,
and we want to make sure
that we keep those
as we're going into
Burning Crusade,
so we have to merge
those changes
with the changes that happened
with the Burning Crusade
originally,
and make sure that we have
a coherent set of changes
that make sense to bring us
from Classic
into the Burning Crusade.
There's an enormous amount of
time spent looking at
"Okay, this is
how it came out now."
We have a reference client,
that is...
the original.
That's right,
we do use the old code for that.
So we still have it,
we just don't want to ship
on that anymore.
We have the old code,
with the old data,
knows exactly
how it's supposed to behave,
so those things
work together,
and we can bring
that up internally,
and take a look at it, and say,
"Okay, this is
how it was back then,
this is exactly
what it used to look like."
And we do sometimes find things
that are bugs
we still want to fix,
but a lot of times
it will tell us, like,
"Oh, this thing is not a bug,
this is actually
the intended behavior."
Or this is something
we don't really remember right.
There's a tendency to
want to chase your own memory,
like, "I remember it being like
this!", and it's like, "No."
It's not always
exactly the way you remember it.
Everybody has
that human failing, even us,
and so a lot of times
we'll have an argument.
"I remember it this way."
"Well, I remember it this way."
"Let's go and check.
We can look."
Well, another reason
to ship on the new code
is really just the years
of stability improvements,
and the fact that the world
didn't look the same back
in 2007 as it does today.
BRIAN: That's true.
There wasn't
cloud architecture then.
I remember, I had the privilege
of being on the live ops team,
where I got to see
what all the servers look like,
and how it was all architected.
And to pull back the curtain
a bit on this, the way it was,
is everything
was its own server,
right, they didn't really
talk to each other very well,
so each realm
had 11 blades on it,
and these blades were just
bare metal blades,
and one blade was for Azeroth,
one blade was for Kalimdor,
one was for Outland...
And then we had some
for instances,
and you know, back then,
what would happen
without cloud is
you would try
to request resources,
and maybe a lot of people were
running dungeons,
and so it would give you back
things like
"Transfer Aborted:
instance not found."
Oh, boy. We don't want to go
back to those days.
So now, we can take advantage
of things like the cloud,
and not have
those resource issues,
so shipping on this new code is
a big improvement in stability.
Yeah, and so we're basically
weaving
all these threads together.
We did finally get it built
for Burning Crusade Classic.
Super excited.
The team gets together,
we're preparing for a play test,
and we go to create
our characters,
and we see...
this blood elf, who, you know,
he remembers the Sunwell.
-HOLLY: He forgot his pants.
-BRIAN: Yeah?
So everything didn't work
the first time?
LAUGHTER
What? I know.
-Yeah, I did mention, we had...
-Sabotage!
...to go check for problems in
those conversion scripts.
And so yeah, sure enough,
what's going on here is
that this guy thinks he's
dressed but he isn't,
and you can see
why he thinks he's dressed--
Does that happen to you a lot?
-(BRIAN LAUGHS)
-Only in my high school dreams.
LAUGHTER
You can see,
if you look at his calves,
you can see
that they're flared out
because he thinks
he's wearing boots.
BRIAN: And the way the system
works is,
we first set the geometry up
for all the items
that you're supposed
to be wearing,
and then we layer on various
images that we call textures,
and we'd use those to build up
a single composite texture
that's then wrapped
around the geometry,
but of course, in this case,
when we were layering them on,
none of the textures
were assigned,
so we just started
with his naked body,
and then was going to go layer
on textures and didn't find any.
So it thinks he's dressed.
It's removed the underwear
'cause it thinks
it's put clothes on,
but there's nothing there,
they're all
completely transparent.
It's like
The Emperor's New Clothes.
He's wearing invisible clothes,
only that's really
what's happening.
-(LAUGHS)
-HOLLY: That's crazy.
And then of course
I wanted to try draenei,
because that's where my heart
lies, I'm an Alliance girl.
(BRIAN LAUGHS)
And this draenei looks to be
heads above the rest.
-PATRICK: That's not the Exodar.
-BRIAN: Yeah.
HOLLY: No, it... Definitely
not.
PATRICK: That's Dun Morogh.
It is,
and that's exactly the problem.
It looks like
the draenei's too tall,
but the real problem is
we're in the wrong place.
And so, yeah.
When you go to the Dun Morogh
character select screen,
of course
the camera's positioned
for much shorter races,
like gnomes and dwarves.
BRIAN: So it's knee-high
on a draenei.
And then, water.
Really, Brian,
we have water in Hellfire?
-BRIAN: Yeah, so...
-HOLLY: Go for a swim?
BRIAN: It turns out that
Outland has
a funny, unique feature
that it doesn't have any oceans,
because the water just
all falls off the edges
and goes out into space,
or something.
I'm not sure how that works
in the game universe.
-Magic!
-BRIAN: But yeah. (LAUGHS)
There's no ocean there,
but we'd accidentally flagged it
to generate one
so we ended up flooding
the entire world with an ocean
until we found that
and turned it back off (LAUGHS).
So through all
of these processes,
yes, we're obviously
fixing what is broken,
but also,
we thought it was a good time
to start enacting
what we call #somechanges...
(KEVIN LAUGHS)
...to gameplay
and how things should work.
Yeah, when you think about it,
with Classic, our guiding
principle was no changes.
Our goal was to provide
as true-to-life,
authentic experience of Classic
that we possibly could
with the community.
And we accomplished that.
What was interesting to me
is to see this vibrant community
that embraced it, and then said,
"Hey, but we're not
exactly the same
as we were 15 years ago, right?"
And they're right.
PATRICK: The times have
changed. The world has changed.
And so, some of those things
that maybe were out there,
that were not great,
and were warts back in the day,
is not something that
we would want to ship again.
Like something that
feels a little buggy,
or wrong, or incorrect,
so the idea behind this is,
let's provide what the
Burning Crusade experience was,
without those warts.
This really, I think,
illustrates the...
The difference
is spell-batching.
We actually had a lot
of requests originally
for spell-batching
in that no-changes charge,
where they said,
"Hey, I remember
when I used to be able to have
two mages polymorph one another,
and they'd both
end up polymorphed,"
and that's cute and fun,
I kind of like that,
and so we said,
"Okay, we can put that back in."
But the system that causes that
is of course
that the spells are batched up
and processed
in these giant batches,
but over the last two years,
people realized
that what that comes with
is about half a second
of built-in latency,
where you push a button
and it doesn't actually take
effect for that half a second,
while it's queueing up
the other ones to go with it.
And people were starting to
find that frustrating.
I talked to a lot of people
who said
they were excited about it when
it first came out with Classic,
but after they'd been
playing with it for two years,
they're really ready
to see it go,
and we're ready
to take it out too,
so we're removing
spell-batching.
That's definitely great.
I remember, every two weeks
I'd get a bug report,
Vanish is broken again.
It was because
of stuff like this.
If you Vanish
when a Fireball hits you...
-...it's gonna pop you out.
-Exactly.
And so we were trying to do
all these techy solutions to it,
but the real answer is
just don't spell-batch.
Yeah.
But we didn't have the ability
to do that then,
-so glad we're doing it now.
-Yeah.
Another one
that I can think of is
how the rating community
has matured, right?
Things were very different back
in 2004, 2005 timelines,
compared to today.
So, the rating community
knows exactly what's going on,
and they want
more of a challenge,
so rather than
always giving them
the last version of the boss,
the final form of the boss,
which maybe is being
hit with a few nerfs,
let's not do that anymore.
Let's give 'em a more
challenging version of the boss.
I'll give you an example
of M'uru, right,
where the initial version
of that boss
had a lot of spell pushback,
and so that made it really tough
to bring casting classes
to that fight.
We did fix that pretty quickly,
and changed the fight
to allow for that.
Now that's a change we probably
would incorporate in this.
We don't want people
to feel excluded,
or not part of being able to do
a fight like that.
But then, probably a month
or so after that,
we nerfed M'uru's health.
That doesn't need to happen.
PATRICK: Let's keep it in the
hard form.
We can evaluate any changes we
need to make after that, but...
Yeah, we'll be like,
"Hey, final form,
we're not even gonna look at it.
Let's call it a day."
Yeah. So how did your mage
handle the pushback?
-Uh, I just... was sad.
-BRIAN: Sat on the bench?
-HOLLY: This feels personal!
-LAUGHTER
No, I was the raid leader, so I
got to choose who went, but...
The one mage allowed to go.
LAUGHTER
That was, honestly,
one of my favorite fights ever
on World of Warcraft.
That was a really fun fight.
That's awesome.
Another change that
we were talking about making is
along the lines of the PvP
balance, and faction balance,
is, obviously,
with Burning Crusade,
paladins are introduced
to the Horde,
and shamans are introduced
to the Alliance,
and that was intended to be
a balancing of the factions,
and let's make them even.
And then they wanted to keep
a little bit of flavor
of that faction identity,
so they kept Seal of Blood
on the Horde,
and Seal of Vengeance
on the Alliance.
It was intended to be
equivalent power abilities
that were just
slightly different in flavor,
but in retrospect, Seal of Blood
was just so much better,
and so one of the changes
we are gonna make
is we are gonna give
the opposite faction's seal
to the other faction,
but we're gonna do
that at max level.
So we keep just a little bit
of that faction identity,
where Horde will get Seal of
Blood at Level 64, on schedule,
and then get Seal of Vengeance
at Level 70,
and similarly Alliance will get
Seal of Vengeance at Level 64,
and then their equivalent,
Seal of the Martyr, at Level 70.
Another thing we want to talk
about is arena teams.
BRIAN: When it first came out
in Burning Crusade,
the arena team system
only let you have
the same number
of players on your team,
that was the size of
the bracket it was for.
So, for example, a 3v3 team
could only have
three players on the team,
so if someone was sick,
or unavailable one night,
you couldn't play.
That felt really frustrating,
so we're definitely gonna go
with the last version of that,
where you could have twice
the size of the bracket
on your team roster,
so that you had alternates
you could swap in and out,
and then that way,
as long as anybody
had participated
in I think 30% of the matches,
then they got the full credit
for the week of participation.
Is that why we did personal
ratings versus team ratings?
That came later.
We're also considering
whether or not
we wanna do something with that,
because another thing that was
problematic about arenas
was the way that the Elo system
was so inflationary,
and so we're talking
about whether or not
we want to move forward with
converting that to something
like the modern MMR system,
so that it isn't
as punishing to people
in terms of waiting hours for a
match at the highest levels,
and things like that.
And another change.
We're going to give
players access
to blood elf and draenei early,
so that before we actually
open the Dark Portal,
you'll have a chance
to level those up.
That's definitely not something
we did originally.
-(LAUGHS)
-Yeah!
I remember, I had a friend who
was really frustrated
that the rest of us were
running around in Outland,
and he was like, "I'm still back
in Wetlands." Yeah.
LAUGHTER
-"What is going on?"
-HOLLY: Yeah.
"When can I play with you guys?"
So yeah, I'm really glad
we're doing that.
-HOLLY: Yeah.
-Is that pre-patch?
-Yeah, that's the plan.
-Very cool.
Pre-patch will come out
and you'll be able
to start your blood elves
and draenei.
And then... content.
So, we've got
some phases happening.
-Yeah.
-HOLLY: Yeah.
So the content phases
that we got coming are exciting.
We're gonna start with Karazhan,
and Gruul's Lair
and Magtheridon's Lair.
BRIAN: And we want to start
with just that at release,
because we found with Classic
that people really enjoy
that gear progression,
and that's where all
the Tier Four gear is,
is with those raids.
And we want people to have
an opportunity to level up,
catch up to their friends,
and all go through
these things together.
So as we unlock each chapter,
we want to make sure everybody's
had enough time to be
a part of that chapter.
And the next chapter after that,
will be Phase Two, which will be
Serpentshrine Cavern,
-and Tempest Keep.
-HOLLY: Yep.
Then next we move on
to Phase Three,
which is Hyjal
and the Black Temple.
BRIAN: And the reason that's a
change is of course, originally,
Hyjal was available from the
launch of Burning Crusade,
but nobody could get in
because of the way the
achievements work,
so we'll unlock that as a later
chapter alongside Black Temple.
And then, that'll go with
Arena Season Two at that point.
And Arena Season Three will
come out alongside Zul'Aman,
with a little bit of catch-up
gear for anyone
who's taken that long
to catch up.
It's another smaller instance,
a ten-man.
And then finally,
Phase Five will be
Sunwell and Arena Season Four.
-PATRICK: Tons of content.
-HOLLY: Been very busy.
LAUGHTER
It is, it's an expansion
with a lot in it.
And so we spent
a lot of time talking
about Burning Crusade Classic,
and Burning Crusade,
which is exciting,
we're very excited about it,
but there's a lot to talk about,
there's a lot coming,
and we want to walk through how
this is going to materialize.
Well yeah,
really the question is,
we have a diverse player base
where people have a lot of
different wants and needs.
How do we get there? How do we
get to the Burning Crusade?
Well, the first group of people
that we wanted to make sure
that we were serving well
is those people who do want to
go to the Burning Crusade.
We feel that most of the
community is interested in this,
they're gonna want to do this,
we want to make it
simple and easy for them.
So, how are we gonna do that?
As we said earlier, you're going
to be able to make a choice.
So we'll talk about and explore
these choices in some detail,
and I'll give you some examples.
(CHUCKLES)
So, to start with, the current
servers you're on now,
Classic live servers,
are gonna become what we're
calling progression servers.
And what that means is,
the servers that are live now
will always unlock
any expansion we release.
So, when we get to
our patch day,
you're gonna be presented
with a choice.
Do you want to continue on
into the Burning Crusade,
or do you want
to move to Classic?
So, in that space,
you're gonna do that
for every single character.
For my example,
I'm on Wyrmrest Accord.
So I've got a Level 60
I'm definitely taking that on
through to Burning Crusade,
but I've got a couple
of mid-levels
that I know I want to move
with my friends.
Those are characters
I have level
with my friends in classing
and I want to continue
that journey with them.
We want to make it
as easy and seamless as possible
to just get right into
Burning Crusade,
but there are options.
Well that's awesome,
I'm excited to hear that.
I know there's a lot of
my friends, for example,
who maybe didn't really play
Classic when it first came out,
and so now they're behind.
And they're interested in
playing the Burning Crusade.
This was, for a lot of people,
their favorite expansion
that we've done.
We want to make sure that
those people are served too,
and one of the ways
we can do that
is provide a boost to people who
are interested in coming back,
but maybe aren't interested
in doing the Classic WoW
experience,
but want to hop right in to
Outlands as quickly as possible.
Yeah, so, the team,
we spent quite a bit of time
discussing it
because we want to make sure
we respect the time
and the people that have been
playing Classic for two years,
but also we want people to
be able to enjoy Burning Crusade
if they loved it the first time
and maybe missed Classic.
So, we are gonna offer
a Level 58 boost for purchase,
but it does come
with some restrictions.
So, it's gonna be
one per account.
It's not gonna be usable
on blood elf or draenei.
It'll have some dungeon blues,
it'll have Level 40 mount skill,
no professions, it's the basics.
Basically your Outlands
starting kit.
That's cool.
That's a really great way
to jump into the game, for sure.
-Yeah, I like that.
-I'll be looking forward to it.
Look, I know a lot of people
came back to play WoW Classic.
That's all they want,
all they ever wanted.
They're like, "You know what?
Burning Crusade, that's awesome,
people are gonna love that,
but for me,
I came back for WoW Classic."
What do they get to do?
What's their options?
Yeah, that was
really important for us too.
So, we had all sat down
and discussed
how we should frame this,
so, when we get
to our patch day,
which is prior
to the Dark Portal opening,
when I said before, I'll go back
to my example, for Wyrmrest,
we will be launching
Classic-era realms
at the same time
as we do our patch,
and you will have that choice.
So, when you make the choice to
go to Burning Crusade Classic,
or you make the choice,
like on my example,
my Level 40 druid,
I want to move that character
to Classic era,
and what Classic era means,
is that those particular servers
are going to stay
in that era forever,
so that is going to remain
Classic till the end of time.
It's never going to
unlock expansions.
You'll be able
to make that choice
for every single character.
Do you go on to Burning Crusade,
or do you choose
to go to Classic era?
Let's say you're behind
the times a little bit.
You'll still be able
to have that choice.
We haven't locked it
to a time window.
You're not gonna miss
the boat to era.
The choice sounds awesome,
and choice in WoW
is something meaningful,
it's always been.
I think it's something
that's important
when we look at the community
that you're gonna choose to go
to the Burning Crusade
or you're gonna choose
to go to Classic.
Some people may not be
comfortable with that choice.
And while we think that
that choice is important,
we also recognize
that there are folks
that are gonna want
to play both.
-Right? Like-- Yeah. See.
-LAUGHTER
Right here.
Maybe you have
some stuff left to do
in Classic that you wanted,
you want to
keep that character in Classic,
but you're also interested,
that same character
wants to raid with your friends.
-BRIAN: That's exactly--
-So what does that look like?
How do we make that happen?
So we're gonna offer
a paid service
to let you make a copy
of your character,
and I know a copy's a big deal,
so like you said,
this is something
we don't want to make
just an automatic choice
for everybody,
but I know that for me,
it really is gonna be that pull
to go to both places,
so I want to be able to say,
like, "You know what?
I'm willing to pay for this.
I want a copy of my character
that lives
in Classic era forever,
while I also go
to Burning Crusade
with that character."
That way,
I can stay with my friends
who are really excited
to go to Karazhan,
I'm really excited
I want to see my hunter
go to Karazhan,
but if I'm missing
a couple pieces
of my Tier Three set
from Naxxramas,
I still have an opportunity
to go find a new guild there,
and go through Naxxramas again
until I finish that set.
We'll be spending a lot of time
communicating these details,
so even as much detail
as we're giving now,
it's very high-level,
there's going to be a lot more
detail to come,
so keep an ear out.
But, with that said... So, Pat?
-Hm?
-When's all this happening?
Oh.
LAUGHTER
Soon.
-Yay!
-LAUGHTER
So yeah, this is something
that's important to get.
People are playing
through Naxxramas,
we want to make sure
they have time to do that,
but we are looking at,
this will be happening in 2021.
For sure,
we're committed to that.
And what we're looking at is
starting the beta rather soon.
So hopefully
that beta will go up,
and we get that running,
the community can come
and participate, help us out.
We'll start to hear
some feedback
on the things
we've talked about today.
If there's any
adjustments to make,
we wanna make sure
we have a long enough
beta period for that.
Then we'll get that out
to the players,
so you can all enter
the Dark Portal.
-Yay!
-Yeah, it's exciting.
LAUGHTER
So, any final words?
Yeah,
I just talked about the beta,
and I will say just
to the community,
you all have been
so instrumental
in making Classic
the success that it has been,
and you'll be equally
instrumental
in making the Burning Crusade
a tremendous success also,
so, please, get in that beta,
play, give us your feedback,
we want to hear
all about it, so...
Enjoy, welcome,
and let's have some fun.
-Yay!
-Yeah.
And it's been the highlight
of my professional career
to work on WoW Classic
and have the support and love
of this community.
It is really special to me,
and I'm really excited to be
sharing this with all of you
in the Burning Crusade.
Yeah, and for me,
I've been playing Classic
since it launched,
and I wasn't working
at Blizzard then,
and it's changed
my life, obviously.
(LAUGHS)
So, from me
and the entire WoW team,
we want to thank you for
bringing Azeroth to life for us,
so we will definitely be
seeing you in game
in whatever flavor you choose.
(CHUCKLES) And until then, stay
Classic.
SOFT MUSIC PLAYS
(MENACING MUSIC PLAYING)
Ever since we
announced Diablo IV
at the last
BlizzCon in 2019,
we've been sharing
updates with you guys
through our blog,
whether it's items,
skills,
zones, even
user interface updates.
You guys seem to
have really enjoyed that.
Today, to mark the
special occasion of BlizzConline
on Blizzard's
30th anniversary,
rather than doing a blog, we're
going to share lots of videos,
introduce a new class, like
we saw in the Opening Ceremony,
and cover some
open world topics, including
mounts,
camps and PvP.
This is the ultimate blog
post. We get to hand deliver it.
This is the dream.
It's all finally out there
and we can talk about all of it.
Just in case some of you missed
it in the Opening Ceremony,
let's take a look at the
Rogue announcement video.
MAN: Your prayers
do not fall on deaf ears.
(OMINOUS MUSIC PLAYING)
Just know they
are being heard.
There is justice
within the Light...
but you
have to be patient.
Now, pray with me.
May Akarat
guide and protect me.
WOMAN: May
Akarat guide and protect me.
May he shepherd my soul...
...and grant it mercy.
What are you doing here?
This is not the time.
But this is confession.
And I have sinned.
I was a thief...
who stole from
those more fortunate.
(DRAMATIC,
PERCUSSIVE MUSIC PLAYING)
I strayed
from your Light...
and found my
trade in the Shadows.
They call it murder.
I say job well done.
(YELLING)
(GRUNTING AND YELLING)
PRIEST: Stop.
Stop!
Enough!
I am a thief...
a heretic...
a murderer, Father.
Will Akarat save me?
(CHUCKLES)
You mock our Light...
but those monsters
were a scourge upon my flock.
And you...
you were the
answer to their prayers.
WOMAN:
Then we are settled.
And you owe me.
The name you seek is...
Thank the Heavens for you.
Heavens?
I assure you, Father...
the Heavens
didn't send me.
(GRUNTING)
(DRAMATIC,
PERCUSSIVE MUSIC PLAYING)
(HORSE WHINNIES)
(SHATTERING)
(ROGUE YELLS)
(SCREECHES)
(OMINOUS MUSIC PLAYING)
Wow, I love that ending.
(CHUCKLES)
There's two things.
There's the Rain of Arrows
off the mount for the win.
Then,
when the guy takes
the ear and he stretches it
onto that hook
right at the end.
It's like...
(SHUDDERS AND CHUCKLES)
LUIS: That ear
box never gets old.
I always wondered
where those ears from Diablo II,
when you kill
other players, went.
JOHN: Now you know.
There's some creepy
guy in a church collecting ears
and putting them in a box.
What we always thought.
No spoilers,
but we're going to be hearing a
little bit more about world PvP
later in the segment,
but ears are
definitely making a comeback.
Let's go
back to the class,
because there's
nothing more exciting
to be able to
introduce to a Diablo game
than another class
for players to check out.
This is a pretty cool thing. We
don't get to do this very often.
I think it was
you that said, John,
"There's always
room around the campfire."
Always a little room.
We had our very core
archetypes to begin with.
The brute
strength of the Barbarian,
the arcane
knowledge of the Sorceress,
a return of a shape-shifting
classic with the Druid.
No RPG line-up is complete
without that dexterity class
that's defeating enemies
with finesse, with speed.
We kept coming
back to the idea of bringing it
to the godfather of all
dexterity-based archetypes,
the Rogue,
that we saw in Diablo I.
You've got to be
excited to have the Rogue back.
I know that when we were
exploring different classes,
you would talk about some of
your experiences with Diablo I.
For sure.
One of the
things that's super cool is
the Rogue was always
able to adapt their play style.
Fans of the Diablo I, Diablo
II Rogues will be able to create
very archetypical Rogues,
starting with
the weapons selection.
On the melee weapons side,
Rogues can use
swords and daggers,
as well as bows and
crossbows on the ranged side.
JOHN: The dagger
attacks mixed with bow attacks,
it just looks
great on screen.
With all the classes
having this
strong identity
as far as the
animations and what they do,
you think about the
Druid and shape-shifting
or the Barbarian
with his leap attacks,
there's these great things
you discover with the Rogue
that you can't really
do with other classes.
I love that you
can start cosmetically
from such an iconic place where
you're wearing the red armor,
you look like a part of the
Sisterhood of the Sightless Eye
from the original games.
You can maybe even
add some tattoos
into the mix, some scars,
make that Rogue your own.
Or if your
fantasy of the Rogue
is a more
traditional RPG outlaw,
you're definitely
able to create that
and put on your
hood and half mask
and be more of a
shadowy character.
JOHN: The character
customization, you mentioned it,
being able to craft the class of
your dreams or your nightmares,
was a feature that I was
nervous about when we started,
because we'd never
had this in a Diablo game.
But seeing
where it is now,
it's one of those
things I'm super excited about,
with where we're at.
There's a lot of
creativity and fun looks.
You can be that
tattooed, criminal outlaw
or you can be a
more noble-looking
thief with good morals.
One of the things
that we kept running with,
beyond the cosmetics,
was customization.
We had this niche
to fill in the class line-up
that spoke to the finesse
player, to the dexterity player.
Everyone's idea
of what that could be
was a little
bit different,
whether it leaned
more on range or melee,
but we took that a
little bit of a step further.
We wanted to have
each class in our game
have that one
thing that makes you go,
"That's bullshit!"
when you see a player use it,
so you want to
re-roll that class,
because no
other class gets it.
For the Rogue,
it's the class specialization.
The 3 specializations
are Combo Points...
Shadow Realm...
and Exploit Weakness.
I like Shadow
Realm, because I can
take the problem
and make it smaller.
I just pull 3 guys
into the Shadow Realm
and duke it out.
Then I come back in
and I'm like,
"All right, smaller problem."
I love the idea of
Exploit Weakness.
The way it works is, during
some of the enemy attacks,
players will see an icon
flash over the enemy's head
during which time
they will be get to retaliate
with much more
damage than an ordinary attack.
If you're
quick on the draw,
this is the
specialization for you.
I'm a little bit
skill-capped there.
Every time I
try to make it work,
I'm just a little bit
shy of the skill level
that's required for that.
It's almost like
you're a surgeon.
It requires a
really strong ability
to assess what's happening
around you.
My personal favorite is the
Combo Points specialization.
As you might expect,
this ability lets you
build multiple combo points,
which enhance your spender's
effectiveness in combat.
Basically, you get
into this rhythm of combat
of 3
builders to a spender.
It lets you build up to
these big, big moments.
It almost makes a
rhythm game out of combat,
which I really enjoy.
The way the class
specializations work
is you will work with one
of the world groups of Rogues
around the world in
Sanctuary that you will find
and do class-specific quests
that no other class can do.
Whether it's the
Sisterhood of the Sightless Eye,
the remnants of that Order,
that you choose to work with,
or the
mercenaries of Kehjistan
or the outlaw smugglers
of the swamps of Hawezar.
Depending on what
speaks to your class fantasy,
or depending on which
specialization speaks to you
or you find more powerful,
you'll be able to
complete that quest line
and activate
that specialization,
which you can mix and match
with any of the play styles.
You could be a Combo
Points, ranged or melee player,
but you can also be
an Exploit Weakness,
range or
melee or hybrid player.
It just gives the
class huge variety
and builds
and play styles.
I love how that ties
into the open world aspect,
the ability to go to
Kehjistan or Hawazar
and get these special
quests only the Rogue can get.
That touches on a
thing I love that we've done,
which is connecting the weapons
and equipment to regions.
When you're
exploring the world
and you pick up
a sword in Kehjistan,
it's a scimitar.
If you're up in Scosglen,
which is up in the north,
it's more of a broadsword.
It's a subtle thing,
but I think it really...
Armors you get
in different regions
look like
they're from the place.
Giving that sense of
place in the world is something
that every time I
play the game, I feel it,
I see it in subtle ways.
It really
enhances the overall sense
of immersion
and experience.
I want to see
what's around the corner.
The weapons are also,
going back all
the way to Diablo II,
such an
integral part of the class,
and the ability to
augment your weapon
through magic, through
enhancements is something that
really spoke to us
when we tried to tap
into the core of the class.
Going back to those
mercenaries that you could hire,
it was always cool to see
what kind of special
arrow shot they would come with.
It's something we paid
homage to with the Imbue system,
all the way from
directly elemental Imbues
like the Frost Imbue,
which feels a lot like
the ice arrows that the
D2 mercenaries used to shoot.
We expanded it
to feel a little gritter,
a little
darker, and do things
like Poison Imbue
and Shadow Imbue.
The ability to take
any sort of attack and mix
and match with those Imbues.
Once that clicked for me,
that I could take
any ability and Imbue it
with either of
those elements,
Rain of Arrows with Frost
and Rain of Arrows with acid
is completely different.
You're essentially
freezing the battlefield.
And I just love
Poison Imbue because of...
the gruesome deaths that
all the monsters experience.
We've had a ton
of fun making that art.
It's always fun to see the
goat men melt into nothing.
You just kill everything
on the screen in a gory mess,
which never
really gets old.
It's a flexible
way to take a build
that you're
already comfortable with,
that you already like.
Say you're really comfortable
with Flurry and Shadow Step
as your melee skills
and you find yourself
needing more crowd control,
without
changing your play style,
you can just add the
Frost Imbue to your bar.
Now you're able to
use those same abilities
to slow down enemies
or build up to a full freeze.
Frost Imbue plays pretty
well with group play as well.
I can freeze an enemy and
somebody else can blow it up.
Or also, the way that
Chills work in the game,
they build up
to a full freeze.
So if your best
buddy is a Sorceress player,
your Chill spells
and your Frost Imbues
will actually
build up faster
than if you were
using a single player.
Ask to open with
Blizzard before you Frost Imbue
and you'll be
freezing enemies twice as fast,
which is awesome synergy.
The last thing
that's worth spending some time
talking about with the Rogue is
how mobile the class is,
how able the
class is to close the gap
between
themselves and the enemy,
even while mounted.
You might find
yourself a full screen away
and dismounting
into a Rain of Arrows,
closing the rest of
that gap with a Dash,
and then getting back out of
there, dropping some caltrops.
They can basically
control the fluid
motion of combat
in a way that
no other class can.
That's
something that, beyond all
of the other customization
options that you have,
whether it's
the play style,
whether it's the range at
which you engage with enemies,
whether it's
the cosmetics,
the sheer
mobility of the class
lets you adapt
to the situation.
Even when you would have totally
been toast as another class,
a room full of elites,
you're able to use offensive
abilities in creative ways.
Abilities like
Shadow Step,
abilities like
Shadow Realm,
abilities like Dash,
you're able to use
them to your advantage
in a way that gets you out
of a very dangerous situation
by picking that
one, lone skeleton archer
that's not
surrounded by everything else.
You can Shadow Step
there, get out of the way,
and live to
fight another day,
which feels like
such a Rogue thing to do.
JOHN:
When I play the Rogue,
I really do feel
surgical precision.
I really feel like I can
move through the whole screen.
It feels
kind of effortless
and almost
sometimes a little unfair.
When I go into the
Shadow Realm and I'm dashing,
I'm like, "Am I
cheating? Did I break the game?"
We'll hear more
about PvP in a little bit,
but I couldn't go
without mentioning
that some of our most
feared PvP players on the team
play Rogue.
It's just the way
they're able to surprise you.
You might be
with a group of friends
and that mobility lets them
go to the middle of the group,
unleash a Rain of
Arrows that's Frost Imbued
and before you
know it, you're all frozen.
Looking at a Rogue while
you're frozen, let me tell you,
there are fewer scarier things
in our game right now than that.
So this was the
ultimate blog post.
This has
been a lot of fun,
getting to share a new
addition to the campfire.
There probably will
be more in the future.
We always say
there's a little bit more room.
That's right. That pretty
much wraps it up for the Rogue.
So, why don't we
go to Joe and Careena
and learn more about those
open world features we promised,
Thank you to Luis and John
for introducing the Rogue,
which I'm really excited
we finally got a chance
to talk about and announce.
We're here
today to talk to you
about Diablo IV
and the open world.
I think the best way to start
this conversation, Careena,
would be for me to ask you
what are you most excited about,
of what we're adding in
Diablo IV in the open world?
What feature,
what mechanic,
what are you most
excited to talk about?
I am really excited about
exploring the world.
I am a huge
completist naturally,
that's the way I play.
I love
exploring and looking out
into every
single nook and cranny.
The more this
game has been growing,
particularly
since last BlizzCon,
the more fun I'm having
riding around the
open world on my mount
and exploring
everything I possibly can.
It's really fun, I think.
Now that
we've taken Sanctuary
and made it so much larger when
you're playing through the game,
when you compare it
to Diablo III or Diablo II.
There's tons of exploration and
movement throughout the world
in those games, obviously.
But now we've
really been able to embrace
the open world concept,
we can dive much deeper
into how Sanctuary
actually all fits together,
be able to ride
from Scosglen to
the Fractured Peaks.
It's very
interesting that way.
One of the things about
that I think is really neat
is the collection
aspect of mounts.
So, there's all
these horse breeds
and other mounts you
can find throughout the world
from completing puzzles
or finding hidden locations
or slaying
particular kinds of monsters.
Find various horses or things
to customize your horse with,
like horse armor,
there are hoof
plates you can get
and trophies to show
off your accomplishments.
There's lots of ways you
can personalize your mount
and make it feel
like your companion.
It's really cool,
like you mentioned,
with the horse shoes,
you get to change the speed
at which your
horse can run.
I like to be able to
customize the horse
to the type of gameplay that
I like to enjoy as a player.
It's really fun.
I like the amount of
variety that you give us.
There's more to
mounts than that as well.
One thing we knew we didn't want
to do with mounts in Diablo IV
was we didn't
want to have jousting.
This idea of
fighting from horseback.
It's not really the
Diablo experience.
Yeah, that's
something I'm super excited for.
At last BlizzCon,
we had the Sorceress.
We showed her
dismount skill, Ice Dash,
where she shoots
forwards off her mount
and destroys
everything in her path.
With the Rogue, we got
to have a little bit more fun.
The animation department
has done a fantastic job
of having her leap up
into the air
and fire down the Rain of
Arrows that destroys everything.
It's really cool.
It feels really good.
JOE: Leaping
from your saddle
and raining arrows down
on your enemies as you pass by,
then get in the fray
and starting to stab people
and poison people,
that is
spot on what
we're looking for.
Being able to jump in, engage
with enemies, from your horse,
and then duke it
out using your skills
and everything
else like we want.
It's interesting that
your mount
can't get damaged,
but if a monster attacks
you while you're mounted,
you will be
forced to dismount.
So, there is a
flipside of judging for yourself
when you do
want to use that skill
to prevent you from being
forced off unintentionally.
There's definitely a
bit of gameplay there
to make sure you use it
in a way that's appropriate to
help you get where you're going
and fight the
monsters you want to.
One of the things I'm most
excited about for the open world
is this feature we
have called camps.
Camps are basically
these strongholds of evil
out in the overworld.
You've got to
remember that, decades ago,
during the
events of Reaper of Souls
when
Malthael rose to power,
the Reapers
killed 9 out of 10 people
throughout Sanctuary.
A tremendous
number of people passed away.
Now there's a big power
vacuum out here decades later,
and these monsters have started
to move into these places.
Bandits, monsters, goat men, all
kinds of different creatures,
skeletons,
the undead, have started
to resurface and
come back into these areas
and take
them for themselves.
You, as the
hero of Sanctuary,
get to wander
through these spaces
and begin to reclaim them
for the people of Sanctuary.
That's part of what
makes them really neat.
Each of them
have their own story.
They're their own unique,
fixed place in the world.
Unlike quests, quests are
something that happen randomly
and you can come
across them anywhere,
camps are a
permanent fixture
that you, as the player,
when you come across that evil,
can actually
have a real impact
on the open world
that everyone else can see.
Because, once you
have defeated that evil,
one of the
really fun things is
that you
basically unlock that camp
and you make a new waypoint that
previously didn't exist for you.
Suddenly all the
marketplaces open up
and now you
have a blacksmith
in a location that
previously didn't exist,
which I think is cool.
JOE: What
we're looking at here,
this was a village,
the village of Qara-Yisu.
Now, it's fallen to ruins.
The people here in the
dry steppes had a problem.
The problem was
there were bloodthirsty
cannibals that dwelled nearby
and would
regularly raid their community.
The people had
to find a solution.
They weren't strong
enough to defend themselves.
So, they made a
dark bargain with a demon
and they were able
to gather enough power
to push these cannibals
out and protect their community.
But not without great
cost, as you can see here.
You're helping re-settle
parts of Sanctuary when you take
these camps back from the enemy.
Vendors will come back
and now there
might be new quest-givers,
new stories
that need to be told.
Dungeon entrances can appear in
some of these places afterwards.
There's all kinds
of things that occur
after you take
over the Camp
and liberate it
from forces of darkness.
Again, it's so cool to see
you permanently change the world
as you find these places,
wander through and
solve these problems.
One of the other
neat things about camps,
and in general the
overworld broadly speaking,
is we have many
more opportunities now
to play with movement.
CAREENA: It
pushes the bar vertically
as well as horizontally.
We now have been
playing around with the idea
of jumping across chasms
to allow the player to
get access to a location
they
previously didn't have.
JOE: There's all kinds of areas
players can find their own path,
allowing them
extra movement options
they haven't had
in previous games.
CAREENA: We
are also in a vertical
top-down camera
for the environment,
so it really breaks up the
plane that you typically see
not only as a developer or an
animator, but also as a player.
There's such
a huge variety
of things that
you can possibly do
to mix it up and make
things a little bit different.
There's certain
puzzle elements to it.
It's not straightforward
or always obvious.
It's not just a matter
of running through the
role and getting to your goal.
You have to think.
Definitely.
Now, Careena,
I know that you're
very excited about PvP.
(LAUGHS)
I'm a huge fan of PvP.
I love the first
time we had a chance
as a whole
team to play PvP.
The amount of
feedback generated,
I think it took Design
3 days to go through it all.
What that showed me is
that everyone
either loves it or hates it.
I personally
love it. I really enjoy it.
The way that
PvP works is that
the Hatred of Mephisto
has been bubbling up from Hell
and has created
these areas in the open world
that you can
freely walk into
that
consumes you and makes you turn
against your fellow players.
JOE: PvP, even in these
areas, these Fields of Hatred,
it's not mandatory.
These are optional
places people can choose to go
to collect
Shards of Hatred
that they can
collect from killing monsters,
from completing
events, opening chests,
all kinds of ways
to earn these things,
not
necessarily killing players.
As you earn
these Shards of Hatred,
they're in an
un-purified state.
They're in a basic state.
You need to bring
them to a Purification Event
in order to turn them into
a currency that you can use
in the nearby, small encampments
around the Fields of Hatred.
What's neat about that
is when you're
trying to purify these things,
that's when
everybody nearby finds out
and hears, "Someone's trying to
complete a Purification Ritual,
we need to go
and kill those players
and take their
shards before they finish."
Once you purify them, they're
yours, you can't lose them.
But before they're
purified, they're free game.
It's really
important to note that,
even if you don't want to
engage with othe PvP players,
you can actually
explore those areas
and collect those Shards of
Hatred from specific monsters,
but the second
you need to turn them in
and purify
them into a currency
where you can
spend them on gear,
trophies and
other content,
you are hostile yourself
and can be attacked
during that single moment.
But, I think that
creates a lot of opportunity
for you to team up with
friends for just that one moment
in order to gain the reward you
spent so much time collecting.
You called out earlier that
the Shards of Hatred are used
for some of the vendors you'd
find in the Fields of Hatred,
there are some special vendors
that only arrive in these areas
who'll have special
costumes or new mounts
and weapons and
things along those lines.
Nothing
strictly more powerful
than stuff you
get in other parts,
but stuff that speaks to
your desire as a PvP player.
I think one of
the things that's neat
about the
system in general is
that as a player,
if you choose to go hostile,
betray the
players who are near you,
try to get as many
Shards of Hatred as you can,
you're going
to slowly begin
to infuse yourself with
that same Curse of Mephisto
and you're going to
become a Vessel of Hatred.
Once you do that,
everyone within a
very large radius of you
is going to be able to
see you as a threat on the map
and they'll get a
bonus for killing you.
So when that occurs,
you have a set amount
of time you need to survive.
If you're able to do that
without running away or
jumping into a town
portal trying to escape,
if you can do that and finish
that period and manage to escape
or defeat people who are
coming to try to destroy you,
you'll get a really
big bonus at the end.
That's been really exciting to
watch in our play tests already.
People are
wrestling for this status
and trying to defend
it once they achieve it
There's also the ears that
you get to collect as a trophy.
It harkens back to D2,
where I think you could...
sell the ears for 1 gold.
I don't know
if we'll do that.
I know we played with
them as a currency at one point,
but I think now
it's just a cool trophy
that you get to
collect and show off.
Yeah, right now,
a very cool trophy.
The thing that was
neat about the D2 ears was,
you could fill up your
whole inventory with them,
being able to see the people
that you took the ears from,
seeing their
character names on there.
It was always the
interesting, fun part
and proof that "Yeah,
I got that person that time."
We want to make sure
we embraced that aspect of it.
That's the important part.
I think that's going
to be a great call back
to Diablo II PvP.
Yeah. I love
where PvP is going
and I love that
it is only one part
of how large
and open the world is,
and really harkens
back to the adventurer in me
when I play the
game. How do you feel?
I'm super excited.
There's so much to
look forward to in Diablo IV.
What we talked about today
just scratches the surface.
In general,
as a Diablo fan,
there's a lot to
be looking forward to
in the
franchise in the future.
Thank you so
much for watching today.
We look forward to
speaking about this game
and others in future.
# EPIC ORCHESTRAL MUSIC
Welcome,
everybody, to BlizzCon.
We know that you
all want to hear more
about Overwatch 2.
Allow us to invite
you behind the scenes
to explain more
of what we're doing
and why.
Everybody, please hit
record. Fingers crossed.
We lost Scott.
It's off to a good start.
This is going great.
JEFF K: We've
been assembling
one of the best teams
that I have ever worked with.
I'm nervous. (LAUGHS)
And I'm so proud of the progress
that we have made together.
I really liked the
stylized drop down.
Imagine that
it's coming forward.
Bom-bom.
It starts to spin.
JULIA: The scale
and the scope of this game
has meant that we've
needed to grow substantially.
STAMMERS
(LAUGHS)
Sorry. Let me start over.
Overall, I think we've
done incredibly well as a team,
moving to work from home.
BOTH LAUGH
Oh, shadow play.
AARON: There have
definitely been challenges,
but the team
is really putting
everything we've
got behind this game.
To me, it's the next big
step in the Overwatch universe.
New heroes, game
modes, major story beats.
DYLAN: With
Competitive and PvE,
I see Overwatch 2 as the
Overwatch for all of my friends.
We're always inspired
by what Story and
Franchise Development does
with their
animated shorts.
We really wanted to
bring that cinematic experience
into the game.
You can invest in your
heroes and grow them over time.
I am super
geeked-out about Overwatch 2.
I can't wait for
people to play this game.
It gets better and better.
JEFF K: There are some
things that we just can't do
without a sequel.
So, thank you so
much for your patience so far,
and I hope you enjoy
this behind-the-scenes look
at Overwatch 2.
All of our players at home, they
want to see one of the new maps
that we've never
talked about before.
Really? I can just, like...
I can just talk about
anything that I want to?
Yes.
You're serving
this up to the guy
that has unintentionally leaked
information in past interviews?
LAUGHTER
You can do
it officially now.
OK.
So, one of the maps that I'm
most excited for in Overwatch 2
is our Rome map.
#
TRADITIONAL ITALIAN MUSIC
We always
want Overwatch to feel
like this globetrotting
adventure for our players,
so we're
having a lot of fun
coming up with the
Overwatch version of Rome.
We wanted a very romantic,
sort of this powerful feeling
of old-world architecture.
One of the most
exciting things for me
is the early
building of these maps,
where we get
to sit down together
with key people from
the Environment team,
level
designers, effects groups.
We'll spend time talking
about moments in the game
that we
really want to see,
like the Colosseum,
or a grand view of the
hills of Rome in the backdrop.
And then we'll go
back and do a paint-over,
or we'll do a concept painting
of certain things based on that.
We try to draw inspiration
from as many
different sources as possible.
For example,
one of our Environment artists
had just taken a trip to Rome,
and he returned
with thousands of pictures
and was so excited to
work on a map set in Italy.
There's a lot of
ancient architecture in Rome
that represents the
empire that it used to be,
so we brought
some of that back.
Some of the things
that are destroyed in real life
we kind of rebuilt
in kind of our
Overwatch style.
AARON: It's one of
the most beautiful pieces
of environment art
that I think we've
made for the entire game,
and it just
absolutely took my breath away.
Can we reveal more maps?
Yes. Scott...
LAUGHTER
Scott, why don't you have the
honor? Why don't you reveal...
Is there an artified...
Pick an artified one.
I know a map I
want to talk about.
It's the one that I
get super excited about.
New York City.
New York City is just an
amazing Overwatch location.
# SYNTH MUSIC
We're really striving to make
it as authentic as possible,
while still putting
this Overwatch spin on it.
DION: There's a
lot of amazing buildings
and
architecture pieces that just,
especially for an
artist, stand out a lot,
and they use this
kind of art deco style
from the 1920s, 1950s.
We started in an area that's
a little bit like the Village.
There's some
smaller shops there,
there's a fire
station, little pizza places
and things that people that
are familiar with New York City
will either recognize
or maybe see the reference
that we're trying to make
with some of our
different locations.
It feels like
something you haven't seen
in other games before
because it's
uniquely Overwatch.
SIREN WAILING IN DISTANCE
JEFF K: Well,
we should move on,
otherwise we just have
to reveal more maps, so...
We were talking about PvP.
And, you know, one thing that
I think is really interesting
about PvP in Overwatch 2
is some of the
philosophical changes
we're making
to the approach.
PvP feels
different and new.
We're
upgrading our combat feel.
The roles are
playing differently
when it comes
to all-new maps.
It's a pretty big departure from
where we are on live right now.
So I can't wait to
see where we end up
with it by the time
we launch this thing.
We're also experimenting with
an idea we call Role Passives,
which are
passive abilities
that a hero can have
based on what role they are.
For example, currently,
in our internal build,
the tank heroes all
have knockback reduction
against them,
and they generate
less ultimate charge
for enemies
shooting at them.
Damage-dealing heroes
have a movement-speed bonus,
which is great for
flanking around the map.
And healing
heroes, support heroes
have
automatic healing that
kicks in after they haven't
taken damage for a while,
very similar to Mercy's passive,
but a bit of a lower rate.
One of the more
shocking changes
that we've been
exploring in Overwatch 2 PvP
is a change to
the tank role entirely,
that's applied
to all of the tanks.
We want to try to make
them more toe-to-toe brawlers,
and less characters that
just stand back
and protect other people.
So, for
example, for Reinhardt,
we've given him
two charges of Fire Strike
so he can throw Fire
Strikes a lot more aggressively
and more often.
Also, his Charge,
he's able to cancel it now,
and you can steer
it more aggressively
so you can not
quite turn a corner,
but you can definitely
more accurately pin targets.
Because you can cancel it,
it allows you to
use it more aggressively
and go after
those key targets
without feeling like
you're going to sacrifice
all of your
positioning to get there.
He's almost
more terrifying now,
being able to unleash
his full arsenal more often
than just being
the guy with a shield.
The changes to
Reinhardt that we're trying -
and they might not
ship, that's just the reality -
but the changes
that we're trying right now
are to try to embrace more of
that instinct that players have
when they
want to play a big,
burly character
that looks aggressive,
and feels like it
should be aggressive.
Shortly after
BlizzCon, we spun up this group,
our combat feel
group, to really just work on:
What happens when
a player holds the trigger?
We're
putting a ton of effort
into looking at
all of our characters
and trying to give them an
even more visceral weapon feel.
From sound to VFX, to animation,
to the design of these units,
all new sounds for a lot
of our weapons in the game,
and a whole new
sound system that's driving it.
We didn't
just level up a unit,
we levelled up
the rest of the game.
When we first
started working on Overwatch,
we spent quite a bit of
time working on gunfire sounds
and just general combat feel
to make it feel really awesome.
We're revisiting everything.
Nothing's off the table.
So we're even
looking at small things,
such as quick-melee
attacks that every hero has.
So they have
a new audio pass,
and a new feel and visual
effect when you hit things.
One of the bigger efforts we're
undertaking for Overwatch 2
is what we're calling
our weapon 2.0 sound pass.
This is a big overhaul to
the weapon systems in the game.
That means the way
the gun feels in your hands.
You can feel the
ammo running out
as you're
getting lower on the clip.
We've really tried
to amplify those sounds
to better
encapsulate the gameplay
and the gunplay that
comes with Overwatch 2.
GUNFIRE REVERBERATING
Key for the weapons
was getting them to feel
like they're in
their environment.
This meant working
with convolution reverb.
It's a new system that we've
implemented into Overwatch.
It's a way that we can capture
the acoustics of an environment
and transport it onto
the sounds that we're using.
So we went and captured tails of
guns in different environments
through our weapon shoots.
GUNFIRE REVERBERATING
Wow.
GUNSHOT REVERBERATES
GUNFIRE REVERBERATING
And then we've
cut them and applied it
so we can support a
lot more environments.
We're now
recording outdoor...
urban outdoor...
warehouse tails...
tight tunnels...
small rooms,
and it gives a lot more
presence to the weapons
in the way that
they react in the world.
The shooter genre has evolved a
lot since Overwatch 1 came out.
On top of that,
we really want to push
the visceral nature
of how we do combat.
So we focused a lot not just
on the wonderful sound effects,
but also with how the
gun moves as you shoot,
so you can really feel every
single shot leaving the chamber.
And there's a lot of subtle
little tweaks we have to do
on the gameplay-engineering
side to make that feel visceral.
Everything from making sure that
the camera shakes are crisp,
that if you get
shot, you know exactly...
These tight indicators show up
on the outside of your reticle.
All these things play
into making the game feel
not just tight
and responsive,
but also
modern and up-to-date.
Take 76, for example.
What we wanted to do in
Overwatch 2 with his weapon
was make it really
feel incredibly powerful,
and that happens with different
elements that mix together.
But it really
feels like the gun
is almost just
outside of your control.
A lot of that comes down to
this camera-shake technology
where, every time
you fire the weapon,
you want to
feel like it's running
through your entire body,
and the camera shake gives
that extra bite
to the visceral shot
out of the chamber.
It makes him
feel really great.
GEOFF: You guys got a sneak peek
of Sojourn from last BlizzCon.
She's been under
development for quite a while,
and she's
quickly, at this point,
become a lot of
people's favorites, in-house.
When we look back at Overwatch
when it was originally created,
there were a lot of
heroes that were made,
from a
gameplay standpoint,
surrounding a weapon type.
For example, Pharah was
based on a rocket launcher hero.
Widowmaker's
clearly the sniper.
We thought there was
a weapon that was missing
that would be fun to
play with, and that's a railgun.
It's so much
fun in the playtest
to have this
really powerful shot
that can rip through enemies if
you really are accurate with it.
She's all
about that aim skill,
so if you've got that
aim skill, you'll love her.
We're still
exploring new game modes,
and we're also
reevaluating older game modes
that people
are more critical of.
You know,
we're of the mindset,
maybe 2CP
doesn't exist in Overwatch 2,
and maybe there's a new,
cool game mode that replaces it.
We really want Overwatch 2
to feel like the next evolution,
a true sequel
to the first game,
not an add-on.
It's not a small part.
It's not an
extension of the original game.
This is an evolution
and a replacement
to the original game.
And I think it's exciting.
Hero Missions are
probably one of the things
that's the hardest to
wrap your head around
if you've never
played one of them.
# DRAMATIC
ORCHESTRAL MUSIC
AARON: The goal
around Hero Missions
is for these to be this
co-op PvE experience.
I personally only
play Competitive mode.
I'm all about
that competition.
And I have friends that
don't want to do that at all,
so I'm really
looking to a game
that I can play
for hours and hours
with friends who
aren't into Competitive,
and it's also
something I'm interested in.
Hero Missions are the
content that people are playing
as they are
levelling up their heroes.
And so, for a
system like this to really sing,
you need a
lot of missions.
We don't want
players to feel like
they're just in this
grind to get to the top.
There's a lot of really,
really good back-end technology
that we're exploring
so that the heroes
are constantly bringing
their personality
and some light story to
these Hero Missions as well.
The goal is to
make as many as possible,
hundreds of Hero Missions.
We've explored a
lot of different ways
of getting to
that much content.
They'll have
different sets of enemy units
that people will
be fighting against,
and there's
different Hero Missions types.
At the same time,
Hero Missions can take place
in all of the multiplayer
maps that we've done,
and we're also adding new
spaces onto some of these maps.
BILL: It's a huge
challenge for the art team.
We take maps that a lot
of people love and recognize,
and we have to add a lot
more art and level design to it.
JEFF K: In this one
Hero Mission playtest,
we came up to
an area in King's Row
that usually
has a gate on it.
Suddenly, that gate opened
and I saw a new
area of King's Row
that I had
never seen before.
DION: You may be
playing a payload game type,
and the payload may
decide to take this new route
instead of
going the usual route.
That was
really, really cool.
It was like this
eye-opening, special moment.
Lan, our Lead Tech
Artist on the Environment side,
very early,
on her own free time,
made a prototype of a sandstorm
on the Temple of Anubis map.
At the time, we didn't know
what we wanted to do with that,
but it looked awesome.
We looked at it
and went, "Oh, my God.
We absolutely
have to do this."
DION: So we put
some new technology in place
that allows us to
do this dynamically.
You start the
mission off, clear day.
Mid-way
through the mission,
suddenly this sandstorm or
heavy weather would show up.
It made the world just
feel so much more alive.
DION: There's a
sunset, daytime, night-time,
but depending on
where you are in the world,
these look different.
California or
Hollywood would have
what we call
a California sun.
In Numbani, there's a great
African sun that happens there.
You start to get a
sense of space and mood.
This is what really
brings the levels to life.
BILL: For me,
the dynamic world's exciting,
just seeing these
dramatic landscapes,
the wind and the
atmosphere blowing by.
It's a much more cinematic
experience for the player.
Before you start a
mission, you look at a map.
It's
night-time in Necropolis,
or there's a
sandstorm in Necropolis.
Players can make
some comp choices
based on
knowing this information.
Characters like
Hanzo or Widowmaker
start to be a
little more valuable
because they have
abilities that allow them
to see through
the sand more clearly.
Are we going to talk about
any of the types of objectives
in Hero Missions?
Yeah, let's talk
about the objectives.
Players are being
asked to do different things
from one Hero
Mission to the next
so that they all feel
really fresh to the player.
For example,
we have Gather and Return,
where you're trying to
grab these different canisters
to safeguard
them so they don't go off
and affect the
population in a negative way.
It creates this
really cool tension
in the world
where, on the one hand,
you're trying to split up
and grab these canisters
to be as
efficient as possible,
but at the same time,
now you're having these
special enemy units spawn
that are really difficult.
And if you get
caught by yourself,
it turns into a pretty
bad situation really quickly.
It feels
extremely cooperative
in a very different way
to interact with the
Overwatch universe.
We're experimenting
with all sorts of ideas.
Just internally, we have
names like Wall of Death,
Scavenger
Hunt and Kill Quest.
With all these
new mechanics
and enemies for
people to experience,
players will be able to
jump in, night after night,
play different
Hero Missions,
and then work
through the progression system,
levelling up their heroes.
# EPIC ORCHESTRAL MUSIC
At BlizzCon in 2019 we started
to talk about progression,
and we showed the very early
version of our Talent system,
which I think
was really cool.
We had that one Talent where
Mei became the rolling snowball,
which was a big hit.
We've really
blown that system out.
I'm excited about Talents.
You can play the same
hero in so many different ways.
Now, with the skill tree,
you can have fun every
night doing different things
and kind of experimenting.
Yeah, the Talent
system is really deep and rich,
and every single
hero has different trees.
You might
open up 76's tree
and, as you're levelling
and picking new Talents,
you're starting to
feel your hero change.
We've had some pretty hilarious
versions of the healing one,
where his Biotic
Field travels with him,
and it also
repulses enemies.
We called it
the snowplow build,
where 76 is
running through spaces,
pushing enemies
away from him. (LAUGHS)
Designing
these is super fun
because we get to break all the
rules that we've established.
We get to really take the
gloves off and do crazy things.
Junkrat can
dual-wield grenade launchers,
and we've had Mercy
wield an area-of-effect rez
on her whole team at once, at
super-long range, through walls.
It's been like a mad
scientist making this stuff.
You're all used to
using these kinetic weapons,
like Soldier: 76's rifle,
or a fire attack, like what
Reinhardt's Fire Strike does.
As soon as you start to mutate
these things with Talents,
all of a sudden,
maybe you're doing freeze damage
or electrical damage.
It gives the animators a
bunch of crazy opportunities.
The animations are going
to change to show them freezing
and shattering,
and if you shock
someone with a lightning attack,
they can shake in place and
maybe chain to other enemies.
Stuff to make you feel
like you're
controlling the battlefield
in novel ways.
As a huge RPG nerd myself,
the first time I opened up the
Talent tree system it was like,
"Oh, my gosh. This is
speaking my love language."
I just want to
plan and I want to see:
Where do I want to invest,
and how am I going
to play this character?
Yes, it's so great!
Like, you start at
the bottom of the tree...
-Yes, exactly!
-Like, "Tracer gets to do what?"
And then you start working
and planning how
you're going to get down there.
It's like... It's so fun.
LAUGHTER
When we look
back at BlizzCon 2019
and we talk about some
of the criticisms that we had,
one of them, as a
development team, that we felt
was that the combat
was just not engaging enough.
So the fact
that our combat
wasn't highly
engaging to us as players
meant that we had a
problem with the enemy units,
in that they just weren't
feeling interesting enough.
Just because we
show something to the public,
that doesn't mean
that is what it's going to be.
If we make
discoveries where
things aren't
working how we want,
they're not reading how
we want, they're not fun enough,
we're totally down to
reinvestigate, reiterate,
and really
find ways to level
all aspects of
things until they feel good.
I would say a
major focus of all of 2020
was to make the Null Sector
enemy units more engaging,
and some of this
was adding new units
and evolving
other units that we had.
Interesting combat for
us is varied combat for us.
So sometimes
we're going to ask you
to protect
something in Overwatch 2.
Sometimes we're just going
to ask you to get someplace.
Sometimes we might ask you
to escort something across a map
while it's being attacked.
So it's a
different type of spawning,
and it's a different
type of units that are in there,
and it's a
simpler objective.
There's a lot of units
Aaron is talking about.
Different
units, different types,
they serve
different purposes,
you do
different things to them.
It's going to help
a lot of us find the fun
and make sure that
Overwatch 2 is a blast.
One of those
sets of enemies
is what we internally
call "objective units,"
and they're typically units
that don't even attack players.
The simplest version would
be something like the Breacher.
It's two legs with this
huge bomb on its back,
and it was
built to do one thing:
Slowly and methodically
march towards its objective.
And then it transforms,
and the bomb
opens up like a flower,
starts spinning
and charging up,
and you hear
this awesome sound,
and you know you
have only a little bit of time
before it's going to explode
and you have to take it out.
BEEPING INTENSIFIES
GEOFF: We have
units like the Slicers,
which you guys
have seen before.
Little... We
call them chickens.
(LAUGHS) They're little
chickens. They run really fast.
We have a guy we're
experimenting with now
who flies and
drops these bombs
that create these
ever-expanding smoke fields
that you have
to escape from
because
they're super deadly,
so you really get to use your
mobility options to escape that.
AARON: There's
things like the Puller.
You could be moving
through these darker alleys,
and as soon as you
hear that Puller spawn,
it suddenly becomes
really spooky and kind of scary.
This very tall, elegant-looking
character that's blindfolded.
Three orbs that circle
around her as her eyes.
And we basically spun those orbs
around her head as a big tell,
launched
them at the player,
and then it
activates this tractor beam
that's bringing you
in and bringing you in.
And then you get
this awesome anticipation
of the hair opening up
so you know
what's about to happen.
RUMBLING
One thing we've
recently been experimenting with
is this idea
of elite units.
We didn't want the elite
units to feel like they're just,
"This guy's got double
health and double damage."
We want to make
sure the elite units have
different
behaviors and attacks.
So, for
example, an omnic grunt,
normally he just fires
his gun, he dies pretty simply.
If you fight
an elite grunt,
his weapon fires
in a burst-fire pattern.
It's very
deadly if you're close.
And if you
manage to take him out,
they don't
just die right away.
Instead, they crawl
on the ground towards you
and you try to back away,
because if they get
to you they can explode.
RYAN:
Artillery, at BlizzCon,
we're all just
staring at this,
like, "What are we
going to do to level this up?"
One of the things we really
felt wasn't coming through
was the damage states.
We intend for players
to shoot these guns off,
but currently it's not
reading as something
that can happen easily.
RYAN: We changed the design,
we changed the animation,
and we go back and forth
and just continually iterate.
We decided,
"Hey, you know what?
We're going to just delete
half of these damage states
so now it's
super readable."
From an
animation standpoint,
we decided on the
spinning-barrel version.
It just did this
really nice kickback.
The tip of the barrel
opens up when it's about to fire
and shifts into
place, and boom!
It's really amazing to
be fighting an artillery unit,
and as you're
shooting the guns on the side
they're visibly
taking damage.
Then you
can blow them off,
and it reacts and
stumbles to the side.
It makes you feel like
you're there and it's super fun.
In a lot of the stuff
we've showed so far,
you're fighting Null Sector.
These are evil killing machines
intent on marching you down.
The way you stop
them is by shooting them,
and we want to make sure that
feels responsive and visceral,
really making sure
that when they take a hit,
it feels like their whole
body has been punched,
almost like
hit by a truck.
That's what
really sells this fantasy
that you're
playing these superheroes.
One of the cool pieces of
technology that we've created
we call
chain-hit reactions.
Oftentimes, you'll find
Null Sector bunched up,
marching, maybe
half a dozen units abreast.
You expect,
if you shoot one,
they're going to
knock into their buddies,
so we made that happen.
Turns out it's
really fun, too.
One of the things that we
showed last year at BlizzCon
was the new
looks for our heroes.
The theory
going in was like,
you want to preserve
the essence of your hero,
but also show
that hero's evolved
and changed
and move forward.
So, we have a
lot more new looks,
so I'm excited to see
how players and fans react
to all of the ones
we've done so far.
Maybe we'll share
some of those new looks today,
which would be cool.
We're going to
reveal McCree's new look
for Overwatch 2,
as well as Pharah,
and we're really excited to show
off some of our first villains,
with Reaper
and Widowmaker.
But first, I wanted to talk a
little bit about technical-wear,
kind of like
technical clothing.
What that really is is
using very techy fabrics,
as well as having very
intricate but functional straps,
designed in a way that is
very aesthetically pleasing.
With McCree, we took a
couple of different approaches.
He's got this
classic cowboy look
that's really
hard to mess with,
because if you try to make him
look too sophisticated
or too techy,
it might not feel
right for the character.
But as a concept artist,
you always want to
change things around
and try different
shapes and silhouettes.
We did identify his red serape
as the main thing for McCree.
We also tried a
couple of different things
with McCree's cowboy hat.
We didn't really want
to mess with that too much
because that's a
very iconic part of him,
so that's another
piece that we kept.
We tried some
retro cowboy looks
that mixed in
some tech here and there,
some that were a
little more techy than others,
some that were a little
bit more classic cowboy.
We gave him a
little bit of a longer beard,
and it really gives
him a nice, more aged look.
What's different about Pharah
than some of our other heroes
is Pharah's
completely covered in armor.
We didn't want to
change her silhouette too much.
It was more about experimenting
on different colors.
So it felt really appropriate
for her to be the one
to harken back to
those original Overwatch colors
of white and blue.
One of the things that we
wanted to update on Pharah
was her visor.
Instead of being completely
opaque and reflective,
we tried a little bit more
of a transparent approach.
And being able to
see through it a little bit now
allows us to see
some more of her emotions.
Reaper was actually the one
I was very excited to work on,
because I could
see a lot of potential
in how we could
integrate his cloak
and his cowl
and his armor,
and how we could make
all of those shapes really sing
within that
classic Reaper silhouette.
We tried a couple of
takes with the first pass,
like completely silver
arms, more layers to his jacket.
Reaper's mask is
obviously pretty sacred to us,
but the thing
you'll notice immediately
is that it's now
completely silver.
Instead of the bone white,
he's got this
almost deadly, edgy silver
that just gives him
that classic Reaper look.
With Widowmaker,
we started with
the ideation stage
exploring a
breadth of ideas.
We tried things like a
more insectoid approach,
a treasure hunter.
One of them made her feel
like a classic Bond villain,
so we kind of
steered it back towards
one of the more
cyberpunk-looking ones,
almost like a
futuristic femme fatale,
which is basically
what Widowmaker is,
but she even
feels more upgraded.
So I'm super glad that
we went down this route.
We played with
different hairstyles, too.
Widowmaker has
the really long ponytail
that's really a
key part of her look,
and we really liked the
hairstyle on one of the designs
that was more of a braid,
and it was an
really interesting look
that also preserves
Widowmaker's original silhouette
with that long ponytail.
We've been working a
lot with our Domino engine
in making our
cloth look better.
Now that we
have this cloth tech,
we're going to
be able to make
some really
cool, unique silhouettes
that will help them
stand out from other heroes.
We've put a lot of time
and effort into our face rig.
What I mean is we're going
to be able to get really close
to these characters,
and it's going
to feel really cool.
It is absolutely
worth the time and the effort
to invest in
the technology,
and that way we can make
these characters do more things
that we haven't really
been able to do before.
It's been super exciting
working on the new looks
for Overwatch 2,
and it's just
been so inspiring
to watch the team try things
that we've never tried before,
and I just can't wait to
show off more in the future.
Overwatch 2 is probably the
largest opportunity we've had
since the
inception of the franchise
to really expand what Overwatch
even means to our players.
In Zero Hour, we saw that some
of the heroes got back together.
But we're also seeing that
there seems to be a second,
huge omnic uprising.
We're going to learn
who's behind that uprising,
why that's happening,
how globally spread it is.
AARON: The Story and
Franchise Development group,
they were
really the torchbearers
of what the big story is that we
are going to tell for this game.
JEFF K: We have a
lot of interaction with them.
They're working on in-game
cinematic intros and outros
for every one of
our story missions.
SCOTT: It's
been really great to see
this
collaboration grow and develop.
The story's just a little more
integrated into our missions
than it ever
really has been before.
All of the available heroes get
dialogue for a given mission.
We have NPCs.
We have
multiple hero choices.
We have all sorts of
events that are happening
that are driving players
to interact with each other,
or parts of the environment,
or other characters.
JEFF C: The world of Overwatch
is this bright, shiny future.
So how do you take
that bright, shiny future
and create conflict in it?
How dark can the
world of Overwatch go?
JASON: The
different challenges
that these characters
have to overcome in Overwatch 2
are things that they
haven't ever dealt with before,
or dealt with
on this scale.
So what we had to do was
literally strip it
down to its bare bones of,
"Where are these
characters in their lives?"
Overwatch has
been disbanded,
and now
there's a situation
where the
world's in trouble again
and the world
needs the heroes again,
but they're
not allowed to be
doing what they
were supposed to be doing.
We started to book
these off-site locations
so we could
brainstorm, over and over,
different versions
of what the Overwatch
2 story campaign could be.
And we basically
had these whiteboards
that we were
carting around everywhere.
The room was
filled with whiteboards,
and we would
write, every day,
story beats
with the characters,
and who was
doing what, and where.
"Oh, my gosh!
We forgot this character!"
JEFF K: We had
these giant sticky notes,
and each one of
them would be a mission
with a
bunch of notes on it.
Somebody would say, "Well, what
if we moved Rio to the end?"
and they would
physically grab it off the wall
and stick it on the end.
We did this for a while,
until we all felt that it was
pretty close to what we wanted.
JASON: Then we could
send that to our writers' rooms.
They then had a
much clearer direction
of where we
wanted this process to go.
JEFF C: Ultimately,
we come up with something
that we think is
right for the game,
and then we pitch it
back to the game team
and they point out
everything we missed.
That allows us
to actually back up,
make it right
and make it better.
JEFF C: Because the
scale of this story is so huge -
it takes place over
the whole world, basically -
it just requires
constant iteration,
constant refinement
to make the story the
best that we can make it.
JASON: From
writing, we go to storyboards.
The storyboards
get crafted with the edit.
From there, it will go
to our Previz department,
where they'll start
to flesh it out in 3D.
Once we've figured out our
camerawork and cinematography,
that will then go to
the Animation department.
And then we end up going
right into the game engine.
AARON: One of our
challenges was to figure out
how to
integrate this story
and this
narrative with the gameplay.
So, the intro cinematic
ends with this huge battle,
this huge war.
When you get into
the game, it has to mesh,
feel the exact same
way and blend together.
We're also
trying to get the music
to be
equally as consistent,
from in-game cinematics
straight through to the mission.
Adam Burgess,
our Lead Composer,
has been working with the
IGC team, with the game team,
developing
themes for all of the heroes,
all of the locations.
As the Cinematic Director,
whatever we're crafting should
never override the gameplay.
We want to make sure
that the player's experience,
from the cinematic to
the gameplay, is seamless
and feels like a
completely immersive experience.
As the engineers,
we have to find a way
to actually make
that come to fruition.
The Choreo tool allows people
to coordinate different events
to happen at
the same time.
Like in Rio,
if you played our demo,
one of the
buildings explodes,
and so that kind of event needs
to happen as you're running by.
And you need
to have it timed,
because if it blows up
too early then you don't see it.
It allows story
moments in missions
that interact
with the environment,
with our characters.
The new tech and new
abilities that we have now
are allowing us to
push our storytelling
further than we
could have previously.
JULIE: What's also
really powerful about Choreo is
that if
somebody has an idea
they can mock
things up really quickly.
We got to
show the Widowmaker
making this
awesome introduction,
and Casey was
able to quickly put
a really rough
prototype in Choreo.
Phillip would
come in, and on-the-fly
he's making quick changes,
they would playtest it.
Something that
would normally take weeks
was done in
a matter of days.
AARON: Each story mission has
its own custom map built for it,
and these maps
are absolutely gigantic.
India's one of our
biggest maps, and it's a fun map
because it has
a few story beats
that we've taken
from recent comics
and
characters in the game.
We've written a
history for each city
so that the
cities feel lived in.
And I think that
informs the artists
so that they know what it
is that the city's been through.
Gothenburg was our chance
to show Torbjörn's workshop.
We created a
space that fits his height,
so there's
stepladders and scalable tables.
We designed the space as if
we were Torbjörn. (CHUCKLES)
Molten steel is
pouring out of walls.
It's pretty epic
when you walk into it.
Toronto is under
siege by Null Sector
when the
players arrive here.
There's a
dynamic snowstorm.
So, as you make
your way through the level,
the snow is
slowly building up.
By the end, the characters
are caught in this
gigantic snowstorm
and they must
fight their way through.
SCOTT: In Overwatch 2,
we want to give you the choice
to be able to play this
character or that character,
so we're
designing a lot of systems
around how their
relationships develop
over the course of the
story missions in the campaign.
JASON: We have a
cast of many characters,
all on screen,
all at the same time,
and it's fantastic
to actually see them
all interacting
and working together
in ways that we've
never actually seen.
We've always thought
about it and hoped for it,
but now it's
actually happening.
It actually
requires us to have
a whole new
branching dialogue system.
If you happen to
have Genji and Mercy
in the second
mission of the game,
you might get different dialogue
that's about their relationship.
JASON: Our voice characters
bring characters to life
in ways that everybody
has fallen in love with,
from inside
Blizzard to the fans.
Just to hear this collection
of actors all together,
all interacting,
has been a real treat.
(AS REINHARDT)
Hammer down! (LAUGHS)
JEFF K: I wish people could
see how many people are involved
when it comes to something like
telling the story of Overwatch.
It doesn't just come
from a singular person,
it comes from a group,
and it's a really talented, fun
group that all works together.
JEFF C: We've been
developing what we hope
is one of the
best stories ever.
There are some key story moments
that I'm really excited about,
and I really can't wait to
see how people react to it.
# EPIC ORCHESTRAL MUSIC
JEFF K: We've been
talking about the game,
about this universe.
I know you all
love it so much.
SCOTT: Right
now, we can sit down
and have a
night of Overwatch 2
and have it be a
really fun experience.
And I think we
need some more time
until we can say
it's perfectly polished
in the way
that we want it.
JULIA: We've made
such incredible strides
since we first
announced this
and showed it to the
community at BlizzCon in 2019.
JEFF K: The thing
that I'm most excited about
is that moment when we hand
the game over to the players.
JULIA: We want
to create something
that really moves people,
that really
touches people.
JEFF K:
That's why we do it.
We create the game because
we want it to
become part of your life,
and for you
to experience it.
# DRAMATIC
ORCHESTRAL MUSIC
For Overwatch 2,
we're upping the bar.
It's kind of
five games in one.
It's a huge undertaking.
ARNOLD: The new tech and the
new aesthetics for the new looks
bring it closer to the
characters that you love,
and we're
just getting started.
The fidelity of the gameplay
experience is much richer.
We are making cinematics
that push the boundary
of what we can
do to tell stories.
We want this dynamic world.
We want things to feel alive.
I'm really looking
forward to being able to
expand the
world of Overwatch
for our players.
We're really trying
to tell this epic story.
In order to
make a game great,
it takes time,
energy, collaboration.
We have just an incredibly
professional team of designers
and artists and engineers.
We just love
bringing this world to you guys.
So many cool characters.
It's just a blast working on it.
Our goal is
for Overwatch 2
to be the worthy
successor to the first game,
to be the next
evolution, to be a true sequel.
We have big plans, so
thank you for sticking with us.
We're going to
cross the finish line
and I know it's
going to be awesome.
I hope people just end up
loving playing it over and over.
That's what we
want to try and capture.
"I'm jumping
in. I'm playing.
(CHUCKLES)
Let's go be heroes."
# MUSIC CRESCENDOS
# OMINOUS MUSIC
We're going to
watch the video sent to us.
WHISPERS
GAME: Now you know what I seek.
Here's the game that it's from.
We got Cain back?
Oh, it's II, it's II!
It's Diablo II remastered.
It's Diablo II
remastered, come on!
GAME: No-one...
Come on!
# GUITAR MUSIC
Show it to me.
GAME: Could this
be our darkest hours?
There we go!
I knew it was there somewhere.
Somewhere out there, I knew.
# OMINOUS MUSIC CONTINUES
Somewhere out there.
It's sick!
Love the campfire.
That multi shot looks awesome.
GROANS
Wow!
No...
And console, okay!
YELLS
Alright.
That'll be interesting.
MUSIC GETS LOUDER
That leap attack was awesome!
Oh!
This Diablo fight is gorgeous.
GAME: Not even death can save...
Oh, Resurrected!
Let's go!
Come on!
That was super exciting.
I am Mr. Llama SC,
I am a Twitch streamer.
I have been playing
Diablo II for 20 years,
streaming it for six years.
I probably have over
25,000 hours in this game.
I absolutely love it.
Seeing the remaster happen,
I have to ask a
very high level question.
Why did you remaster right now?
Diablo II is a very
special game to Blizzard,
as many of you will know.
Diablo II also had
its 20th anniversary.
We wanted to stay true to what
that authentic experience was
for Diablo II
and bring it to
the current audience
and improve it for
the existing audience
and invite new people
to experience
it for the first time.
It's also a good
learning opportunity for us,
especially when we're partnering
up with Vicarious Visions
to work on a
remastered project together.
It's been great.
We've actually
worked with Blizzard
for a while now,
a couple of years,
starting with some
Battle.net type things.
We just finished
Tony Hawks remaster.
Before that we
did Crash Bandicoot.
It just seemed like a perfect
match for us to work together.
It was a shock to my system,
first to come in and see
that it's a remastered trailer,
I was not expecting that,
but then to see
the complete shift
in the design
and art and everything.
I'd really love
to hear more about
how you came up
with the process for
how you wanted to
remaster the look of it?
How you wanted
it to visually exist?
I'd love to
bring in Chris Amaral
to talk about some of that.
Chris, can you discuss
a little bit of the philosophy
and the design
decisions around this remaster?
Luckily, we had a
ton of good inspiration
from the original DIIR.
Our primary
focus is always nostalgia.
We want to focus
on getting this right,
and deliver an
authentic experience
that players
remembered from 20 years ago.
Every choice we make with
the art, models, environments,
should really
ignite that nostalgia
and reinforce that emotional
connection from the original.
We came up with
a 70/30 visual guide.
70% is basically the classic.
This is where we
don't touch what works.
We want to maintain those
iconic shapes, colors, tones.
Everything should be one to one
and faithful to the original.
We want things
that feel authentic
and preserve original designs.
With the 30% new, that's where
we're going to elevate that art.
Every change should
signify that step forward.
I also noticed
that the game was 3D.
Can you talk a little
bit about the discussion
or how you moved and some
challenges moving from 2D to 3D?
Evolving from a 2D image
game to 3D is very challenging.
We basically had to write
a complete new PBR renderer,
a physically-based renderer
on top of the old game logic.
It's difficult because
you're dealing with models
versus 2D sprites,
where you have dynamic
lighting, you have dynamic VFX.
A lot of that is
an additional system
that we have to
work out on our end.
The follow up to that
question, I suppose is,
I wasn't able to see any items
when I was
watching that trailer,
are all of the items
going to be remastered,
all of the gems,
every single piece of this?
What sorts of flavor did you
decide to add to that artwork?
We remodeled everything
because everything
has to drop in the game.
You have your icon art,
and then you have your
3D space art, that flips right.
We had to
basically model everything.
As far as the inspiration,
we were inspired by
original documentation
that we found
from Blizzard North.
There was a huge Word doc,
where the original
artists pulled inspiration from.
A lot of that was
historical landmarks, locations,
very much real
world referencing.
That was where we
pulled our inspiration as well.
We wanted that functional design
that the original art had.
Everything felt believable.
That detail really does help to
give it some realistic context
and makes you feel
more immersed in the game.
It makes you
feel part of the world
when you see
every buckle and strap.
ROB: I remember when
we went into the tavern,
and there was garlic
hanging from a beam.
We're like, what's the garlic?
This is all full 3D.
They said, there
was garlic in the game.
We go back and
it's four white sprites.
You're like, "Holy cow!"
There's garlic and
hams hanging and everything.
It was really cool to see
it almost for the first time.
It's funny because
original SD was made in all 3D.
We actually came
across a bunch of screenshots
that were a different camera.
It wasn't the isometric camera,
it was either marketing
arts or something else,
or maybe exploration.
There was shots of
that garlic in the original art,
you just could never
really see it in the pixel art,
but it was there.
It was telling
that they were
trying to achieve something
very grand with this art.
I'm not going to lie,
I never knew they
had garlic hanging in there.
Maybe a couple of white sprites,
I thought they were candles.
Who knows?
No clue.
That makes me
excited to go look around now
and just explore all
of the areas in the game
to look at the new
detail and see what's there.
It's good now too
because the one new feature
on the art side of things
is a zoom camera.
It'll help you get in there
and look at all the details.
It was something
I really felt strongly.
A lot of ARPGs that
come out have a zoom feature.
This will really get you
up and close and personal
with like your armor,
your weapons, the runes.
ANDRE: Another way to look at it
too is our legacy toggle feature
where you can flip
back between the old visuals
and our current visuals.
It's not even just
a simple art swap.
It is really the old
game running underneath,
because like
Chris was mentioning,
our new graphics engine
is running on top of the game
and is mimicking
what is running underneath.
It's still following all
the same data and rules
and timings of everything.
We are still being true
to that 25 frames per second
of what the game is underneath,
but rendering it in a way
that has more frames per second.
I'd love to hear
more about that specifically
because when I go into
Diablo II, I'm thinking 25 FPS.
Like you said,
that game is built on that.
My faster
casting, my hit recovery,
all of this stuff
is built on 25 FPS.
How do you
create a game at 60 FPS?
All of the logic and how
the game talks with the server
and everything like that
runs on that cycle
and that hasn't changed.
We still have benchmarks
in all of our content,
say for animations of
when a hit frame occurs,
how long it can
recover and all of that,
that all matches exactly.
Now it can run at
a faster frame rate.
Modern games
run on time, not frames.
We've done that,
but all of the logic still
runs on those same things,
so you can wait for
your breaks to occur.
All of those things still
happen at the exact same time
and that was through no small
effort, but it's super important
because even if you
can't see it right away,
you feel it when it's different.
We've done
that on lots of areas.
For example, the original
game only had so many sprites
to render your rotation.
You'd have your character
rendered out at so many angles,
and the monsters even less,
but you could actually
walk at greater directions,
I think it was 64
different squares around you
that you would path to.
You'd have feet sliding.
We've increased that,
so now there's more granularity.
It's 3D, your
character can run straight,
but underneath the hood,
this is a game made
back when the
inspiration was tabletopgames,
so the game is a grid.
It still respects that grid.
The controller will still
allow you to move small amounts,
because you
push the stick a bit,
but you're either
in a run or walk state.
Still, stamina is a
thing, you're on a grid.
All of that logic, once again,
is all being
driven by the old game.
That hasn't changed.
Rob was mentioning animation.
Animation was very challenging,
because you only had a few
of the frame counts basically
to make the animation.
It wasn't like a modern game
where you have
tons of different keys
to make it very fluid animation.
We had to really like maintain
that timing and that pace.
The posing was a
big focus for us too.
We wanted to get those
iconic poses for each character,
then align that silhouette.
Continuing to talk of visuals,
I want to talk about characters,
cosmetics, how they look,
because something
that I love with Diablo II
is putting on a Scale Mail,
a Full Plate
Mail, a Sacred Armor
and seeing the character
have the different change,
but some things
still don't reflect over
in the color of it or whatnot.
Some do, some don't.
Is there going to be changes?
Or is it just
enhancing all of those visuals
and making
them look even cooler.
Our goal was to
basically be one to one
with parity with
the original game.
We built every piece of armor
that was in the original game
and is in the
remastered version.
The only difference
we did is with the icon items
so we now we have a more
connected visual with the icon
and the item that
drops in the game.
Before you
had different visuals.
That's really the only
thing we've pushed on as far
as modernization.
Shields or weapons,
a lot of the unique
items you find in the game
had special icon arts right.
That is
something we'll be showing
on your
character in the new visuals.
That's something that a
lot of people would love to see,
to have the cool stuff actually
on their character there.
It will be the
same see on those icons.
Are we going to see remastering
of the cinematics in the game?
-Yes.
-Yes, we are.
The entire full 28 minutes
or whatever is
going to be all remastered
with new high fidelity art.
It's going to look
amazing by the way.
Will the sound in
those also be remastered
and any other sound in
the game be remastered?
All of the audio
has been remastered,
and we've added additional
surround sound features.
There's more ambient,
there's more effects going on.
It's just a richer experience
if you want to
play with your full setup.
However, we have to use
that measured hand as well
with audio.
There's just a lot
of very iconic sounds
that we really couldn't change.
If you put a skull into
your inventory, that pop noise.
MR LLAMA SC: Don't
change my skull sound!
Exactly!
There are
certain things you'll hear,
for your footsteps running,
we'll have some variety.
When the rain kicks in,
it's going to have more depth.
When you go to the jungle,
you'll hear more
life in those trees.
There's some
sounds we couldn't mess with.
With Blizzard,
when we're creating new games,
one of our design philosophies
is what we call 'find the fun'.
When we were
looking at DII again,
we very much felt
like the fun is still there.
It's actually one
of our core pillars
for Diablo II
Resurrected specifically
was to keep the fun
and keep it at its core.
Because of that,
we were looking at it more
as a remaster at that point
and what can we do based
on what the community wants
or what features
naturally are necessary
for making this game run on
modern day systems and things.
I think also, we want to thank
and appreciate the fan base.
This is really a true
nod to the original game.
We want to preserve that game
and structure as much as we can.
If we went with the remake,
it would be a
completely different game.
I think that was
why we chose this.
Speaking from my experience
or from some of my
community's experience
and the discussions we've had,
we definitely felt
like with Diablo II,
a remaster just
seemed like the way to go
because, like you said,
there's so many of those
tiny details within the game
that create, overall
when you add them up,
such a big part of the
experience of the game.
Remaking that into a
new game could be a challenge,
and could also be a challenge
in keeping the fun
of the game in that way.
I look at it a little bit
like StarCraft: Brood War,
which also had a remaster,
and how a lot
of the pathing bugs
and the duds from the reverse,
all of these things in the
game that were kind of awful,
are what make the game beautiful
and what make the
game super balanced.
If you were to go and remake it
and remove some of those issues,
it would change how
the whole entire game plays.
I felt like with Diablo II,
that's kind of the same idea.
You've got to keep
some of those difficult details,
because then it ends up
creating the overall experience
that we all know and love.
We also felt that for a game
during this time back in 2000,
based on limitations,
where everyone was still
looking at strategy guides,
or just limited internet,
it led to that typical
game design you see
where there was a lot
of mystery and discovery.
We felt like that was
another part of keeping the fun,
which was to maintain that
discovery of the game as well.
Speaking to maintaining
and possibly changing,
what are the pieces that
did end up staying the same?
Or if it's easier to
explain the other way,
what are the pieces
that were really changed
to bring this remaster to life?
At its core, we want
this to still be the same.
Right away,
things like the balance,
the monsters
you see, spawn rates,
item drops, and things like that
are the same.
What we're doing is
trying to take any of
the rough edges you see,
compatibility
issues, resolution issues,
and obviously,
improving the arts as well.
All these things you've
come to know from a remaster,
but still maintaining
very much what the game is.
When it comes to
the features we added,
this is
probably the biggest area
where we scrutinize so much.
Is this addition
straying too much?
Does it still create the
same gameplay experience
and other things like that?
So...
Things like a shared stash.
We know people
use mule characters,
so adding a shared stash,
we felt was the right choice.
We have a shared stash?
We have a shared stash.
Oh, thank God!
LAUGHTER
ROB: Now the way that the shared
stash works is there are rules.
You can't have
your ladder characters
mixing a stash with
a non-ladder character.
Your offline characters
can't use your online.
But, we were like,
people do this
anyway with a mule character,
so it's okay to give them this.
That is like the greatest
feature that you could add,
because there's nothing
worse than opening up the game,
going in, dropping all your
GG items to mule them over
because you've run out of space,
and then not
being able to log back in
or the games not
created or didn't perm,
and losing all of your gear
or trying to find someone
to help you
transfer your gear over.
Oh my gosh,
a shared stash is amazing.
Thank you so much.
That's such a help.
Like I said,
maintain the core was a thing,
but the other aspect of it
was to see where we can improve.
The shared stash is one,
because we saw it as
a very common concern,
especially around muling which
people had workarounds anyway.
That is one thing.
Another example is we are
reimagining the UI in the game.
With a reimagined UI,
we're still trying to stay
faithful to what you expect.
You'll still have the classic
globes on the HUD screen,
the skill icons,
the potion belts and all that,
but we are reorganizing a bit.
We're trying to
integrate the menu buttons
and the stamina
bars closer together
within the HUD,
so it's a bit cleaner.
Naturally with reimagining a UI,
we have some
liberties to add a few things.
Going back to the information,
a big thing we're
doing on the character screen
is adding an
advanced stats screen as well.
We're going to be showing you
all the information
you get from items as well,
so you don't
have to do that math
with looking at
each of your items
and calculating how
much magic find you have.
It's summarized there for you.
Something that we've
seen already in a lot of mods
where they've
taken that information
and created a little screen.
That's really nice to see.
that you guys are
implementing that as well
because, yeah, I don't
think anybody likes sitting down
and counting up the magic
find of every specific item,
you know,
and all of their charms
and all of
everything to figure out
what is the
number, how much do I have.
We've also added auto gold.
So, you can opt in.
It is a feature
you can turn off,
which is one of the
things we have to be careful
and a handful of other
things, where we're like,
if you want this,
you can turn it on,
but you can also keep it off.
This was something
that we started looking into
when we were
adding controller support.
There's a lot of paths that we
could have taken
with controller support,
obviously for controllers
on console,
which we're coming out on,
but allowing you
to just plug that controller
in for accessibility reasons,
for that might be
the way you want to play.
But it's a PC-first experience.
Like, for example,
there's still an inventory grid,
there's still inventory Tetris.
That's core to
what Diablo II is, right?
Taking that away,
it starts to become,
you know, something different.
MRLLAMA: And I love that.
I think that's the perfect way
to really introduce it
because you're gonna have
that split in the community.
You're gonna have
half the people who say,
"Just give me
auto gold, it's 2020,
I don't want to worry about
having to pick up
every individual gold stack."
But then you're gonna have the
opposite side of purists who go,
"Don't touch this,
like, that completely changes
my game experience.
And if I'm speed-running through
the game
or playing through whatever,
I want to be able to go over
and pick up the gold stacks
and take that time,
and that's more a part of the
Diablo II experience for me."
I want to jump back
to features in a second.
But before we do, you
just brought up console play.
And I feel like we
have to jump into console,
the decision for console,
and how you're
going to make that work.
We already talked a
little bit about like auto gold,
having that be a
little more accessible.
But when I think of Diablo II,
I think of a mouse
going and clicking everywhere.
How does this work on a console?
To say it wasn't a
challenge would be a bold lie.
CHUCKLES
So, there's a couple of things.
For the most
part, the game thinks
you're still using a keyboard
and mouse with a controller.
That was almost a
rule we kept, you know,
that helped keep us on the rails
because we didn't want to be
sacrificing, once again,
that authentic experience,
but we did want to
make it more accessible,
bring it to a modern audience.
I mean, there are people who
were born
after this game came out
that we want them
to enjoy it and play it,
and a lot of those
people are used to, you know,
just more modern titles
that could use a controller.
Also from an accessibility
of just allowing you to plug in
a controller
helps for many other
people to get to enjoy the game.
The biggest thing I think that
we are...
the two big things we'll say,
one is you're changing
the way you play the game
from being kind
of an eye in the sky
and telling your hero
what to do by clicking on areas
to actually being your
character and directing them.
So, pathfinding is gone, right?
Because you're doing
the pathfinding
and things like that,
which creates some
very interesting things.
For example,
the Sorceress's Teleport
is meant to teleport
you to wherever you click.
So, in that area, when
you're playing on the console,
we will have a
kind of a default distance
that you will teleport to,
whereas on the PC,
you can click wherever you want.
Same with the Barbarian's Leap,
although that one's
interesting because it levels,
but it's become a
very, very fun challenge.
Like, I'm a Necromancer
and I need to target an item on
the ground
that has a certain keyword.
It's working so far,
but you guys will be
the ultimate judgeof that.
SPELLS FIRING
ANDRE: Yeah, we've had a
lot of talks back and forth,
play-testing
and things like that.
You know, a big challenge
we had too was categorizing
all those 300 character skills
to see how each
of them really played
to see what
challenges there were.
And like Rob mentions,
the Necromancer Iron
Golem is a favorite of ours
to continuously talk about
because of the
various ways it can target,
also like a Sorceress's
Telekinesis is another example.
Watching the trailer,
we see the Assassin and Druid at
the campfire,
we see a Druid casting Tornado.
I have to ask
though, even still,
this includes Lord
of Destruction, right?
This is going to be a
full encompassing remaster
and not just
classic or just a piece?
That's correct, yep.
We are going to be including
both the base Diablo II
and the expansion
Lord of Destruction as well.
And we're even keeping the mode
of playing
non-expansion character as well,
so you can still play a classic
Barbarian, for example,
and things like that.
OK, awesome,
'cause that was something
I was also going to ask,
will there be Classic Mode?
Because, once again,
when you go to the purists,
you always have the
people that go back all the way
and they're like,
"Classic is pure, and that's it.
And I won't play anything else."
That's very much
what we wanted to keep.
Even based on popularity,
it might not be as much,
but it's still a
part of the game
and it still leads to
interesting ways
of playing too, right?
A lot of it's
even data-driven, too.
So, a lot of the reasons to
keep it were pretty clear to us.
Like, let's make sure we're not
taking something away
from this remaster.
I'd love to go ahead
and start talking about
some of the other features
or continue talking about
that you had mentioned before
because hearing each of these
already has gotten me
so excited for this game.
And so what are
some other little things
that you felt could be changed,
wouldn't change the
whole flow of the game,
but just
improve it a little bit?
One thing we're looking into is
making it easier to
interact with your stash,
so having quick keys to
move to your stash is one thing,
versus dragging the mouse
every time you want to move
something in your stash.
Other things we're
looking at as well are
like an item
comparison tool tip.
So, in case you're
looking at some other item,
you can you can hold shift
or whatever
controller button is mapped
and then you can see
what equipment items you have
just for quick
glances, things like that.
ROB: The item comparison is a
great example of us adding it,
but added it with
a measured hand.
So, we don't
suggest any gear for anybody.
The gear in Diablo II
is so quirky and different
and every class
can use everything,
that us
recommending things like that
actually was more
confusing to people.
So, literally you hold Shift
and it's like, here's what you
got equipped, here's what it is.
I think that's the great way to
do it with Diablo II,
'cause I agree, I mean,
that's one of
the best parts about Diablo II,
the items are so fantastic,
so unique in their own design,
that it would be near impossible
to have a tool tip
that could
recommend one or the other.
You know,
because it's all so unique
to every situation and character
and skill build and everything.
We added five more languages.
So, that's a
feature to a lot of people
who speak those other languages.
The whole front end is
pretty much modernized now,
so your
character is much bigger,
front and center,
right in the beginning.
And you'll have a backdrop
of whatever act you're in.
So, that's all been streamlined.
You can still, you
know, play online or offline,
but that flow has been improved.
So, what are
your favorite changes
that each of you have
within the game so far?
There's a lot of fun...
It's fun to see a lot of the art
come to life
with our new visuals,
so, for me, one of the
things I've been waiting for
since, like, first
starting on this game was
to see that character creation
campfire scene come to life
in our new art.
And I'm really happy to
see how far it's progressed
and I love seeing that.
It's just such an iconic moment.
It's the first thing you really
see in the game
before you get started.
And it's amazing.
Can I see all the art?
No, I'm just kidding.
So, we added,
like Rob mentioned,
we added like an act-specific
screen in the front end.
And it's
basically this large screen,
we have like a
diorama of each act.
And it's just amazing to see
because it feels
like you're really there.
You can see the detail,
you can see every
aspect of the scene,
and it just has that
very immersive feeling to it.
That's probably
my favorite part.
I think mine is a
little bit more squishy.
I think our game
has gotten a little scarier.
And I think that there are
certain areas
in the game where...
just the way that,
you know, the 3D lighting is
and the way the sound is,
and I play it on a big
screen TV sometimes,
and just it feels scarier.
It feels creepier,
a little more claustrophobic
in, you know, certain areas.
That's not just one feature.
There's a lot of
things going on there.
But I think it's
really, really cool.
I would like to hope that,
had the original creators
had the tools we have today,
it's the experience they
would have wanted to make.
I think the lighting really
helps with that too
because we're a 3D game.
That's one of the biggest
differences
between the original games.
So, what the game
had before with the sprites,
with 3D
models built into sprites,
was not a true
real-time lighting system.
So, because we're pushing that
with a 3D graphics engine
running on top of the game
and getting actual 3D lighting
inside of those kinds of caverns
and corridors
makes for a very
interesting experience now
because it just
feels more immersive
with having light
react around you like that.
Yeah, I would definitely
say, I mean, I've only seen
the trailer piece you sent me,
but even from that
just seeing like
down in the tunnels
or the sewers
or any of those, like you
said, cavern, dungeonous zones,
the lighting,
it was darker and brighter.
And then things like
the skeletons and the fire,
it just had
like this different...
I agree, creepier feel,
though I haven't
seen much more than
or anything more
than you guys showed me.
But there was definitely
a different feel to the game.
And I loved the
fire the most I think,
just watching the
Sorceress's Meteor
was like... gorgeous.
Fire and lightning, once we got
all the effects up and running,
there was
definitely a couple of times
where we would be just
in a review and we were like,
and ten minutes
would go by and we're like,
"Oh, crap, we had a meeting.
We're just playing now."
Another thing that kind
of goes without saying that,
just because it's parody,
but 8-player multiplayer,
that just works,
but, once again,
it was tricky to get that going.
So, with multiplayer,
are there going
to be any changes,
any differences in there
from PvP to trading
to how players
interact, you know,
units blocking each other,
I mean, all sorts of stuff?
So, with multiplayer,
we want to keep all the features
you've known and loved there.
So, PvP will still be there
down to like opening the party
window and engaging hostility.
Trading is still going to
function the same as you know,
you know, you can go into games,
trade items or talk in chat
channels and things like that.
Areas of improvement
though were, like I said,
going back to my mentioning
of reimagining a lot of the UI,
improvements to
the bounded lobby.
So, we were trying
to look at some things
like improving how
you browse server games
so when you're
looking at a game to join,
and typing
passwords and things like that.
That's the kind of area
we're trying to see
how we can smooth out in ways,
like making sure you
can browse Normal games,
Nightmare games and Hell games,
even though you've graduated
to the higher difficulty.
I'm sure you've known that...
There's nothing worse than
accidentally
killing Baal in Nightmare
when you're trying to do
Nightmare Baal runs
and you're like,
"I can't find any of the games
anymore
for Nightmare Baal runs."
But you can if you
log into a separate game.
Right, you go to a
separate character.
But that was
kind of our logic, right?
And since there
are workarounds there,
that made it easier for us
to make the decision of
allowing some of those things.
Another change
is also looking into
reducing ladder seasons overall.
So, right now, ladder seasons
in Diablo II are six months,
and we're looking
at reducing that as well
to help have more engagement
and kind of drive
more incentives too.
You know,
six months is a long time.
And we're looking into,
like, if we make it shorter,
we could probably have greater
beats throughout the year
as well as seeing
people strive harder
for getting like to
that level 99, right?
So, is there going to be any...
reward change on that?
Or will it just
simply be, you know,
the same standard,
you get to 99,
you're 99 on that leaderboard,
and, I mean,
that's a giant reward in itself.
But I don't know,
if there's any other piece
go up on the
Battle.net website or something.
We're not looking into adding
anything beyond
what the game really did,
but in some ways
there will be some things
that kind of come out of
because of what we change,
so we have the
leaderboard, right,
where you can see
each class going to level 99.
There are easier
ways to filter through that.
And we're also
looking into saving that, right,
so you can always look back
to previous seasons as well.
So, in a way we're
creating that kind of legacy now
that had kind of
been dropped from the past.
So, that's one advantage,
is your names could be there
in the legacy
to look into the past.
I mean, I think that
would be cool enough,
just anything to keep
it there as like a forever,
like this was season
one, season two, you know.
Like, that's when I got my 99.
Because I know a lot of
people like to go and reflect
on their old characters
and pushes and stuff like that.
Character exploration will not
be a thing anymore, by the way.
Due to modern
Battle.net integrations,
you will not have to worry about
refreshing your characters.
-So, they will stay with you.
-Awesome.
Will there be anything different
with like character
names then if that's the case?
Oh, yeah.
So, this is one
that we talked about
for a very long time.
So, because we are
moving to global servers
and we have cross progression,
we will allow duplicate names.
Because with
everyone being in the same thing
across all consoles and all
platforms
and other things like that,
you would very
quickly bump into duplicates,
like day one.
And so we are
allowing duplicate names.
However, they
will also be appended
with your gamer tag
or your Battle.net ID
or other things like that
so that you are still unique.
But this also allows us
for people to
play the game quicker
because we can
autofill in your name
and other things like that.
Rob touched on it a little bit,
but another mention there was
going to global servers as well.
So, this is a
new thing we're doing
where the concept of US
West, US East, Asian regions,
and the EU
are no longer
going to be a thing
in terms of like
being on separated servers.
So, now for the
push for a global play,
with Diablo II,
you can now be able to join
across people around the world.
I think that's a
fantastic change.
That's always been one
of the saddest parts is, like,
they're on EU and I'm on US East
and then my other friend
is on US West and it's like,
how do we get us all together?
OK, somebody has
to make a sacrifice there.
And so this seems
like a really positive change.
So far, you guys are killing it.
I'm loving all,
I mean, absolutely.
I just want to say like
I'm loving all of the changes
and all of the
decisions that have been made.
It feels like you're respecting
the integrity of the game,
but really bringing in
a lot of that quality of life
because Diablo II just
had some of those pain points
like muling and separate servers
and all of that.
So, I just want to throw
that out there really quick.
There's a lot of love
and care going into this,
like, we're very passionate
about Diablo II, you know.
I can even give
you a little anecdote
of when I started on the team.
I was asking around
too, naturally as a designer,
I want to know as much
as possible about the scheme
in order to make good
decisions on a remaster.
So, I asked around,
like, what kind of files
and leftover archives do we have
from before from Blizzard North?
And I was given some
and I was told that was it,
which I quickly disbelieved
because I like to just
do my own little digging
around to find out things.
So, I dug around a
lot in a lot of archives
and I looked around
in different teams as well
because naturally,
a game from 20 years ago,
people have
moved on to different teams
and like where has data
moved around and across
our other games across Blizzard.
So, it was within folders
within folders, I like to say,
that I found a lot of old
source files from Diablo II,
like within folders of saying
"stuff we should archive."
And there was a lot
of stuff to archive indeed
because there
were a lot of things,
like, we're talking
model source files,
old tools that
Blizzard North used
to create the
sprites and things like that,
all these things I spent
months and months organizing
and communicate
that out to the team
and help getting Blizzard
library team
and other people to help out too
to help share as
much information as possible,
which helps a lot
with when we're adapting
some of these models and whatnot
and making new art out of it.
Because, you know, sometimes
those pixels aren't good enough,
and if we have some
kind of source model to look at,
if we have it, now we can
make even closer decisions.
On that day when he found that,
I think that really
helped me greatly,
like we sent all that imagery,
even the models
I think we sent over
to the outsource
teams and different art teams,
which they used as
like a stepping stone.
The only piece of art
we actually reused one to one
were Tyrael's wings.
We actually
took the Tyrael wings
from the Mac file
and then just
repurposed that for ours,
like we did very little work,
very little
modernization of that,
we just made it work.
But, yeah, we did
follow a lot of the rules
that the old game actually used
for, like... another
example is the Succubus,
the Succubus in which, I
think the old was a North model
they reused the
Assassin mesh for the body,
and we did the same thing.
We used our
Assassin mesh for the Succubus.
ANDRE:
A lot of fun discoveries
that we're making
the same decisions on
in interesting ways.
Another example too is
because we found a lot of stuff,
there's a lot
of old texture files
for some
environments on the game.
So, another example is like
the walls you
see in the Act 2 tombs
with those kinds of
like paintings on them
are the same
textures we're using
because we found
the source files for those.
CHRIS: Any symbology
we have questions on,
we always like
jump into that archive,
try to find some kind of source
or reference or something,
and we just reuse it
as much as possible.
We want this to
be as true as possible.
That can even carry
over to the cinematics too,
like a lot of the cinematics
cover the same locations.
Think of like Tal Rasha's
tomb with Baal in front of it
and there's all those
ruins going on behind them.
Finding sources like that to
try to match as much as possible
was a goal
and I'm glad to say we
did find those kinds of things
and they're
matching it very well.
So, it's helping
our cinematics too.
There was even
concepts we repurposed,
like we found a couple of
concepts that were amazing
from, you know, 20 years ago,
the Blood Hawk
and the Blood Hawk nest.
And we used that completely
to rebuild our new asset.
MRLLAMA:
Fascinating.
I feel like I could just sit
here for hours and hours, days,
as you guys talk
through every single thing
you found in the source files.
I could too. I'm still
organizing it to this day.
I still could find
something I could work out.
As I put it, I'm very
meticulous with this stuff
because I love it so much.
I'm
categorizing everything, like,
this is everything
I found on War Eve.
This is everything I found
on the Greater Mummy
monster or Baal or something.
And then if Chris
comes to me and needs help
with like some
kind of way of identifying
what parts of the
creatures are something,
I even go through links of
seeing
if I could open up those models
and actually like
re-rendering them out in a way
that we could actually
see it in higher detail,
and see, like, what...
Like, oh, the Greater Mummy is
showing
part of his bone on his knee,
so we should try to match
that or something like that.
And there's a lot of interesting
stories and references
that we actually used
to create the new art
by re-rendering models out
to see everything.
Yeah, it was literally
like video game archaeology.
And then even learning
how parts of D1 were made,
parts of the code
that were commented out,
totally geek out
on just all of the...
you know, because it's a game
that we all kind of grew up in
and a lot of us got
into the games industry
because of these types of games
and this game
in particular, right.
And so it was almost like
we were treating it
like a classic car, right?
Like, OK, it probably shouldn't
run on unleaded gas anymore,
but you really
can't change it, right?
You just got to make
it, you know, good enough,
even better, you know,
than they remember
and good for another 20 years.
Yeah, and even like
you mentioned, Diablo I
is very key too, like,
we look at Diablo I as well
because naturally this
being a sequel to Diablo I,
especially within the
timespan of when it came,
like Diablo I,
you know, was 1996
and Diablo II, 2000,
a lot of things carried
over throughout development.
So, going back to see
Diablo I and what it's like
also helped us make decisions,
even some of the art too because
we discovered certain things
we didn't even realize before
until later down the line.
Like, an example is
in the Chaos Sanctuary,
you see a lot of
statues with these Black Knights
and those are actually
the same Chaos Knights
you see in Diablo I.
So, like sometimes some of the
things I find,
even source files from Diablo I,
were useful for us for reference
so we can make the new
statues and things like that.
Even the Sorcerer
and the Act 3 Hireling
shared very similar models,
like it was just
an addition helmet
or a little bit of
detail on the chest,
but that was
really the difference.
You guys need to do
a just like developer
archaeology discussion
at some point where you just
sit down
and talk through all of this
because this is like the most
fascinating stuff I've heard.
I mean, I've
played so much Diablo II
that I know so many
intricacies of the game,
but, like, when
there's more to be discovered
it's like, oh, man,
I'm like itching to know.
That's the funny thing.
The funny thing is,
going back to our, like,
core philosophies on the game,
we wanted to keep discovery
in the mystery and stuff.
Because you keep discovering
things all the time
when you play Diablo II,
like all these little
hidden rules and information.
It kind of carries that
fascination over
through development as well
if we find a lot of
things in the code,
design documents
and models, things like that,
that were really fascinating
to see how they were made,
and I learn something
new every day on the projects.
One thing, shifting
back to the online play here,
I know there's definitely going
to be questions around security.
How are we handling duping?
How are we handling bots?
How are we handling, you know,
just anything
around that, round-downs,
and all of the disconnects
and all of that good
stuff that we deal with online.
What's being taken,
or what action is
being taken there?
So, moving over to
modern Battle.net helps us
with a lot of
those types of things.
To say it's,
you know, lock-tight,
I wouldn't dare do that.
That's like throwing a
gauntlet down to the community
to try to break it.
But all of that should
be far more secure now.
Now, we do still allow
you to play offline, right?
You will need to authenticate
that your copy is legit,
but after that you
won't be bothered.
And so, there's a reason
why we leave those characters
quarantined away from online.
I mean, yeah, we have
a server team working on it
and these are
some of their efforts.
We want to stop the bots,
stop duping as much as possible.
There's a lot of strides
happening
in the back end of things.
So, I'm excited
to play this game
and I'm sure a lot of
other people are very excited.
How can we sign
up for this closed beta
and when will this
game be coming out?
ANDRE: Actually, we will be
doing a technical alpha
and you can sign up
on our webpage today
for future waves of invites.
As for the game itself,
it will be released in 2021.
Well, I just
want to say thank you
to the
remastering team right here.
I absolutely am blown away
by how much effort
and how much passion
you guys are
putting into this game
and just into Diablo II.
I've loved
Diablo II for 20 years
and I never thought that
the game could get better,
but I think you guys
are respecting the integrity
while upgrading and
adding and improving,
and I think this is going to
overall just better the game.
So, thank you guys so much,
I appreciate you having me on,
and for all the
hard work you've done.
Awesome. Thank you. I mean, your
praise means the world to us.
I mean, you and people like
you who keep the game going,
for 20 years, like that's...
If you guys didn't do that,
this might not
be happening, right?
We see the
passion in what you do
and what your colleagues do.
So, thank you even more.
And thanks for
coming to do this, this was fun.
# OMINOUS MUSIC
HIT SOUNDS
GAME: Not even death
can save you from me.